we got this you have like the the blank burger bots thing that you used for your announcement you're just gonna goink it i'm gonna goink it's just the title of the game man i'm gonna put my youtuber on there instead and be like my homework man i didn't just just goink i'll give you look i'll give you my thumbnail and then you can copy and paste your face off over it too if you want Oh yeah,
I could give you like a PSD or something if you want.
Yeah, you can just copy and paste your face onto this one and then swap my face to yours.
Oh, I have a thumbnail maker because I can't be fucking bothered.
I need to get like a formal thumbnail maker.
My problem is I don't plan what I'm doing in advance.
I basically go live and I'm like, chat, what should I do today?
And at that point I'm already like, you know, I can't make a thumbnail at that point.
like oh my god yeah like yeah i think i'd schedule a so i at least my thumbnail maker can be like here's my schedule making thumbnails i think it's okay then okay i'm a sociopath okay we're oh you're so annoying yeah like oh my god like we're misproductive like this is the person going above and beyond yeah look bad i was just like okay using her time productively didn't take a fucking two hour nap before the collab and actually used her time.
It's a two hour nap.
You're supposed to only take like a 30 minute nap.
Hold on, I'm cranky right now.
Do you have like a really shitty PNG of your face so I can paste you over me and then I'll paste that over you?
Yeah, just specifically me.
Give me a second.
Yeah, don't worry.
I got you.
I need to put your face on me and my face on you.
I got you give me a sec let me what if I uh where the fuck is it here's okay I got you here you can use this all right I just put Mimi on my screen no it needs to be the tired face because oh yeah it's true oh wait I should oh my tomato doesn't have the tired face I didn't add eye bags on this one you the tomato I'm pulling your stream up life now i'm i need to give you guys little hats give me i'm still missing there you go here i'm gonna have to like tilt myself is this my god this is insane i'm saving this show up her mode oh my gosh yeah why i'm gonna show that it looks like you just walked behind like i went to 7 11 and you just like quartered me into the alley yeah i'll be like right behind you no what's that I'm like,
no, I'm not a human.
Oh, I'm like, I'm just showing up at the door.
That's me.
I'm not okay.
I'm just trying to, I don't know why.
Okay, I'm trying to make, like, Mimi's Fuggy to work, but she doesn't, like, Fuggy refuses to, like, make her appear on my screen.
Wait, I thought I was the one not appearing.
No, you're, you're on, you know, like, when you post the Fuggy link, and then, like, she doesn't, they don't show up.
Like, I'm not coming.
to work today guys yeah we just hired me and she already missed the first day of work your thumbnail editor is a try hard and put a filter on our png so oh yeah sorry for me for paying my thumbnail maker a good amount of money yeah if i can try it try hard sorry for paying my thumbnail maker wow it's fine i no don't worry about it it It'll look better for the lack of actual effort put in.
Yeah, exactly.
It's funnier like that.
Okay, guys, I'm still trying to get me on to onto my screen.
Do you want a PNG or something?
Okay, I got her in.
Okay, I had to, like, make a new source file.
I think it's more fault, Doki.
How is it my fault?
I still haven't given you guys little hats, though.
I have, like, four ears because your ears are so big.
I can't cover them without making me impossibly huge.
So now I have like ferret ears and cat ears sticking out from my bloodline.
All right.
That's the new meta.
Everyone becomes a cat girl.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, man.
We want to explain the game we were originally going to play.
You know how people thought we were going to do a severance watch a party?
Like what?
That's what they thought.
Yeah.
People were like, wow, are you doing a watch party?
We're going to do a watch party severance or some shit.
Yeah, man.
No, it was a game.
It was a game where it's literally phasmophobia, but someone can play as the ghost.
from like the dev and it seems like they were like people were like they should add this to Phasmophobia and they were like I already try to tell them to add this and they said they'll never do it we'll never do it that's like crazy I was like oh well that seems kind of silly so now we're back in the kitchen yeah and then they seemed like they had their shit together until like you know like i was gonna fucking download the game like two days before and then i was like why does this just say 2025 like what what do you mean it is 20 i know i was just you know but you know how it's supposed to give you like the date of like um of when it's gonna show up so i just got so confused i was like wait did it not tell us the release date why the fuck did we organize this collab on saturday No,
there is, yeah.
It was a release date.
It disappeared.
He posted an update.
It was like something, there was like a, some bug with his build and so the scheme rejected it.
Yeah.
Like I had to look it up on, because I was like trying to find like Dev's fucking social media platform and his only social media platform was TikTok for some reason.
I had to link to TikTok.
Yeah, I was like, but I find so many games on TikTok.
Like this game, I found it on TikTok.
was he using his real voice or was he using the ai voiceover i have to know i don't remember it was just a text it was like this game is gonna be delayed because they don't check games on the weekend i was like gross big girls um we might need to swap games now in trouble god forbid the steam staff have the weekend yeah wait wait so does that mean like they didn't In advance Apparently they uploaded it on Thursday or so Late night at Thursday And then So then they're like Guys,
I don't think they're checking the games Like They're like, oh it takes like Five days to approve a game And so they're like I don't think they're going to be able to finish checking the game Like Yeah Oops Oh well Alright I finished my thumbnail If he finished putting hats Yeah,
we all have hats now Yeah, that's the amount of time Wait, what does the thumbnail look like i want to see oh i posted it in discord it's really high effort oh yeah let me see oh it looks good it looks good i actually couldn't tell yeah oh god new outfit debut outfit upgrade all right who's gonna make the server he's gonna host it who wants to be the regional manager oh i'm in the middle oh yeah so yeah okay yeah yeah because i'm a west sea like a nice a nice flow to it manager yeah the regional manager i'm gonna cap the frame rate on this game because every like every one of these games that we play that's like early access and stuff is like hey what's optimization and if you don't cap the frame rate it just I didn't see an option.
Yeah.
Oh, I just do it through the NVIDIA control panel.
Wait, there's like, there's proximity chat here.
Wait, there's push to talk.
It says it's recommended, too.
It says proximity.
All right, guys, time to...
So we're doing the mute.
Okay, I can't wait for the next call.
Okay, when we're in.
When we don't realize we did that.
I just did that.
I just did that with Mimi.
Every time.
All right, wait, there's only push to talk.
You can't even do open mic.
What the fuck?
There's no open mic?
open mic wait isn't there no i'm gonna put that on my mouse button it says wait if i oh if i uncheck push to talk maybe maybe i'm gonna uncheck push to talk and see all right i'm starting to send invites now all right if i disappear it's because i crashed i gotta i just realized i have to unprivate my friends list so i can join your lobby i saw you though yeah but i don't see I don't see Lymo and I don't see snuff.
I'm still just launching the game.
Also, I'm on Invisible, so give me a minute.
Yeah, we don't want people to know what we're doing.
I bet you...
She doesn't want people to know she's playing Ork Massage.
Sometimes I hear that Mint plays V-bridger.
What a freak.
Oh, my God.
Maybe that's what...
Why did...
I'm going to un...
All right, let's see it.
My profile.
Friends only...
Wait, no, I think it's only...
Yeah, yeah.
I think it's regular.
I think it's not Push-To-Talk and then you can activate Push-To-Talk.
Yeah, yeah, that's what I'm saying.
You can take Push-To-Talk if you want to.
Alright.
How do you then, like, what's the button for Push-To-Talk?
Let's go find out.
It was V.
Yeah.
Fixed it.
Okay, I will see you guys in game, I guess.
Okay.
I need Can you invite me again?
My invite's not working.
Yeah, mine is an adder.
Uh-oh.
I'm sending.
Okay, it didn't work again.
Oh, we didn't even just said you're in V Bridger.
We can't join.
Oh, no.
Wait, what do I do?
Wait, I'm looking at Browse Games, and I don't even see your lobby.
Usually you have to like...
Because I turned it in by...
I'll leave it.
Yeah, do friends only.
Yeah, soul.
Do friends only.
Friends only.
Yeah, see, she has friends, guys.
Oh, my God.
Why would you think I don't have friends?
No, I didn't say...
I didn't think you.
you guys can probably find me searching for games no games found searching for a game is it because you said me too uh what you can do is if you add vbridger to your private games on steam it won't show people you're playing it which oh my god you're so smart how do you do that you right
Is it properties?
Oh, Mennon.
Hide this game.
Yeah.
Wait.
And Mark is private.
Mark is private.
Do you just hide it from yourself?
I don't want to play video anymore.
Mark is private.
All right.
Now no one will ever know.
No one will know.
This is where we have to like actually restart because it still says you're playing V Bridger.
But yeah, you got to restart.
Uh-oh.
I have to restart.
Let me see.
Maybe Lyme should be the regional manager.
I think Lyme is way more capable than me.
How much like ping do you really need to play this game?
It'll be fine.
We're fucking flipping burgers.
I'm going to leave the lobby.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Now we're just out of wait for Lyme.
This is very lethal coded.
I'm going to say.
It is.
It says like.
Rent is due in three days.
Oh, that's very lethal.
You know how I found this game?
You know how?
I mean, I found this game because there's like less than 70 reviews or some shit.
Oh, look, I can join Limeo.
I like...
Oh, someone needs to invite Numi because we're not official friends.
All right.
Drama exposed.
I'm in.
Oh, Jesus.
Oh, my God.
They're laughing game.
Okay, I'm going to mute everybody.
Goodbye.
Look at us.
It's just our fucking profile pictures.
I'm sorry.
Okay, I'm muting too.
Wait, wait, I'm muting!
No, no, I'm like muting on Discord.
Oh god, have you got a weird name?
Oh, I know where you are.
I know what you are.
You're different.
I know what you were.
I know what you did last night.
I just like accidentally on Megalo reacted.
I just, I just muted everybody.
The drop.
I muted everybody.
everyone too I just love how we're I just love that's just her fucking profile pictures
it's so silly so silly all right we know that they're not in yet okay there's snuffy there's snuffy we just got I don't know why limo isn't I like your faces yeah
We're just waiting for it.
Neem me.
Yeah.
Snum.
It gets me every time because I always forget.
I was typing snuffy and it was like, no, there's nobody called snuffy on your list.
Oh my god, are we all here?
I just been like, how many other snooze do you know?
What?
I just typed the name.
No, oh my gosh, the sensitivity is so high in this game.
Give me a sec.
It really is.
I have to turn everything so far down.
Yeah.
What's the...
Oh my gosh.
I'm not...
Oh my god.
Now it's way too low.
Welcome to Sloppy's.
We have franchised into space.
I like the zoo.
Oh yeah, what is zoo?
What am I doing?
Wait, you're dead.
Wait, how do you even...
Here we go.
I love working at Sloppy's, guys.
Yippee!
Sloppy, it's free real estate.
I can't tell either.
We have to do.
Oh my god, you're dabbing.
You're dabbing, Snuffy.
What's dab?
Oh, what button?
We don't know because we can't see ourselves.
what am i doing clapping oh no wait wait what was that one what am i doing wait am i just flexing what the did you just do i think that's seven yeah that's seven it's kind of a flex but actually because there's not that much detail on the rings it kind of look like you just
all right we have to welcome neemie into the the the family we have hired a new employee in the Sloppy's franchise.
Sloppy's in space.
This is her orientation.
You are very welcome to be here.
Looter gold.
She loves minimum wage working.
I think we just join in.
Like, yeah, it's just random.
I'm pretty sure.
I think so.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, end of episode one.
Because it's...
We look like we're at a...
We're gonna like...
You're like, Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary.
What happened to me?
Oh my god, wait, I think it activates Bloody Mary.
If you say it Bloody Mary three times.
Bloody Mary?
What did you do?
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
No, I would do it.
We'll watch from here.
What happened to me?
Betrayed you again.
Big fireball.
What?
What happened?
Maybe it's only once.
Why did you all the way up there?
Wait, wait, wait.
Stuffy, you activated her.
You go.
You go do it.
It's nothing.
Try it again.
Yeah, try it again.
Okay, Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary.
And then I just turned around and there was like somebody in the hallway and you think killed me.
Oh.
Bloody Mary.
Wait, do you think it was, do you think it was just a regular customer that came into the hallway and just killed us?
Because we weren't.
It was my box.
You knew I was buying time in the back.
You guys hit the blowout command.
your boss was like, hey, hey, there's you ain't getting overtime here.
Bloody Mary.
Yeah, maybe it's what, yeah, we gotta wait for day two.
Okay, so, take a new order from a customer by ring...
What?
Oh!
Oh my god, she...
Oh my god.
Did you not shoot her?
Yes, no, if you had a gun.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god!
What happened to me?
You can slip on your I blew it up.
Oh, yes!
No!
Guys, my helmet is getting cracked, guys.
I can't...
I broke my helmet.
Wait, Mint died!
Guys!
Mint's dead!
Guys, by the way, I read that when you die, you can't come back until the next day, so...
Um...
Alright, well...
Alright, sorry, Mint.
Yeah, we'll...
We'll cover up over there, and it'll be okay.
Oh My god, it's just like old time There's like a fun ride Down here, you guys A fun ride?
Fun ride?
But she like stunned She like a shocked hamster?
Yeah?
Wait, it
powers!
Wait!
And- Oh my god, it says insert me to operate!
Like, what are we operating?
Again!
shit yeah we gotta be careful guys wait there's a tunnel there wait we have a bath yeah every sloppy meal comes with a side of min's head there is i got a bat yeah she's dead until the next day like we sort of fucked up what is that oh look at these whack Wee!
Wee!
Oh, Doki just died.
No!
Oh my god!
Yeah, I can hear you.
Who would have thought...
If you whack, if you whack it, they fight back.
Maybe?
Maybe we're serving them spider burgers.
I whacked it and it fought back.
Oh, who would have thought it would do that?
Yeah, who would have thought it would self-defend itself?
Like...
Yeah, that's crazy.
Yeah.
It's insane.
I can't how dare they fight back like you didn't you did not know who I am Also, you're gonna get thrown into the We got we're running at a burger meat Oops, this is the easiest work day of our lives.
We haven't even started the work day It just We haven't even clocked in yet Okay, now we gotta see if we can actually put them on a burger
just watching snuffy carrying your head around i'm watching dimmy carry around oh so too much yeah i think so too i think the left side is the tutorial but we're not paying attention there's this start the workday by using the switch it's even under Lied,
man.
What the fuck do you think?
Oh my god, please start the work.
Just start the work day, guys.
Please start the work day.
I like Halloween decorations.
Oh, is there?
Okay, wait.
Oh, it is.
He slipped into the garden.
My head.
Your head, though.
Heads will roll.
Happy Halloween.
Oh my god, they finally...
finally start the workday.
Oh, I can make us a freaking logo.
Snuffy, no!
She's distracted.
Now she got distracted by MSP.
What do you think the color of the sloppies is?
Limeu is going through the cave.
I like how Snuffy was like, I'm gonna start the workday, and then she found the PC.
Just, let's see.
Mostly green.
She can't help it, she's a V-tuber.
Oh my God.
I just saw her...
Oh my gosh, she got meat!
I just saw Lama got meat.
Yeah, yeah, she got like some bugs.
Yeah, yeah.
Also to my sound guy, I up the overall volume for everyone.
We haven't ever had Amber before.
You what?
Oh, I was talking to my sound guy.
He was like, make sure to up, up Mimi and Snuffy.
I was like, gotcha.
Find it, yeah, it's a box of patties.
How is the audio for people?
Yeah, how is the audio, everyone?
media guy.
Dibu, please start the day!
Dibu, please!
The switch is right there!
We're never gonna play this game!
We're just like watch partying.
You know what?
We are watch partying severance right now.
We are... This is our watch party.
Oh, I can mute you.
No, no, no botch.
I swear.
What is that so sad?
Really?
Let me cook.
That's like the best day on the job is when you can convince everybody's at their match.
Yeah.
I think it's just also...
I think you just up the overall volume and then like turn people down individually.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, Lymu can turn on the fucking jukebox but not start the day.
Like...
Bloody Mary.
Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary.
We're gonna be dense.
We're just...
This is our purgatory.
You know, get everyone nice and relaxed for their burgers.
I feel like I should be like, you know, free, like, I don't know, just talking this.
Like, hey.
Oh, please start the day.
Please.
this is this we are truly this is it this is where we're stuck for this is what we're stuck watching fast food workers figure out how to fucking start the day like that's our punishment please
fast food purgatory this is actual real pain this stuff is still trying the logo she is still on the PC.
I can't, we can't even see the logo.
Brought us up at all.
They completely forgot.
Yeah.
Oh, I need to start the day.
No people don't.
I told her I was doing too sorry.
We're in Bergen.
Okay.
What?
I can't hear you anymore, Loki.
Wait, can you not hear me?
I said apply the logo.
I know.
Oh, I see the logo.
Wait, that's so good.
Yeah.
Wait, who is so...
Oh my god!
That's not the button!
Oh thank god!
Just end the day!
Oh my god!
Wait, I think if they all...
If they all like...
We're not gonna do it...
Kill each other.
Oh, horse qu- They all kill each other, then we can come back.
I'm handling a burger by placing a bottom bun on the burger.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Okay, I don't think they're gonna do that.
We're just gonna watch them make a burger, I guess.
There we go.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's just- Finish by adding a top bun and pressing the wrap.
Oh, there's a dog!
This is like- This- Oh!
There's the customer!
Oh, shit.
You know what's good for you?
Whoa!
He's so aggressive.
This is our tutorial video, Mint.
We're literally watching our tutorial video.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
She didn't stay back.
He warned us he had anger issues.
You should let the customers have his job.
You should let me.
Um.
So stay back.
Hello.
Welcome to the purgatory.
Yeah, welcome to the purgatory.
Can I take your order?
Thank you.
Thanks.
That was something.
Ben and I were watching all three of you try to start the day.
Right?
We just didn't have an orientation.
But we just didn't have an orientation.
It's not our fault.
Our regional manager didn't give us an orientation.
Yeah.
Exactly.
That's not our fault.
There you go.
Is that guy still just walking around?
Yeah, he is.
I think he's walking around till he gets his burger.
Alright, it's just Lamu left.
Hey, Snuffy, welcome to Burgatory.
Yeah, welcome to Burgatory.
Can we take your order?
I thought you guys would come back to life when it started.
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
Yeah, we come back to life on the next day.
so I think Lymu should just die yeah Lymu should just die there's no way she can she's gonna shoot the customer
that's not very sloppy of her oh she slipped she slipped on her She slipped on Snuffy's blood.
Hey, Snuffy, okay?
Guys?
Hello?
It's just self-taking orders.
I haven't figured out how to make a burger, man.
Which, okay, Glimu is our tutorial.
Yeah, this is our tutorial video.
Alright.
Well, the guy she killed, though.
Like, what do you do about it?
Yeah, what do you do about him?
Do you just...
You gotta make him a burger.
Wait, maybe she can use the customer to make more burger meat.
So we'll never run out of meat.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
We got the meat from the bugs downstairs.
Let's see.
So we have a box of birds.
Oh, my gosh.
She tripped him.
They can figure out how to make a burger again?
Yeah, she's still trying to figure it out.
She shot a customer, but we don't talk about that.
She shot a customer.
all right let's see she's definitely the manager then yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what we cause like i want to talk to your manager and we said limo with a gun
wait that's not fish you fucking you they grinded our bodies we're probably dead i haven't figured out how to open the burger box yet there was a rest there was a red part we don't even have bodies, man!
What is this machine?
Get in the fucking tube.
Oh, it's the res, but I think...
It's the res machine.
Maybe there might be a recharge.
Yeah, me too.
We grinded your guys' body and we're going back.
It's like the res cost us money.
We need to never come back.
Oh, it costs money to revive.
Yeah, yeah, I saw that.
I like how Lima brought Mimi back and she's like, okay, figure out the burgers.
Oh, that's cute.
That's cute.
Oh, there's some orders.
Oh, there is.
Yeah.
I like how she basically revived Mimi just to delegate her some tasks.
Just like real fast food.
Yeah, just like real fast food.
It seems to be working.
So you know what?
Actually, I'm going to do that.
Who's frying with the meat?
Wait, oh, maybe they're in here.
Hold up.
What about in here?
Oh, there's the meat!
Oh!
Oh, of course they'd be in the fridge.
What is that?
Customers will get angry?
I wonder if they have like a rage mechanic.
Okay, so one...
I'm going back there to eat some things.
Surprise.
Okay, great.
Where's my partner?
How do you know when it's done?
You just oh, I think I think it changed color, right?
Yeah, it turned like less red
All right Patty Patty cake cut Oh, oh, that's so immersive.
I love that Yeah, yeah, it did a little beep Oh, really?
Alright, so we need someone to do the fries I think Mimi would be perfect for fries and then I can flip the burgers.
What order is it?
Shit, what number is it?
I want to take the order.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Wait, who's going to be the front?
Who's going to be Squidward at the front?
No, wait.
What the hell is going to look?
But they all left.
It's right here, man.
What is going on with that man?
We're never coming back.
He's never in the burger machine.
It looks like he's like banging his hand on the floor.
Like, he's like, oh, darn.
Nimmy's gonna put him in the blender.
Wait, is she?
Oh my god, she is.
She's putting him in the blender.
We were running out of meat.
Wait, she's gonna revive him.
I'll just put the way into the tray.
No, I think she's blending him.
Yeah, I think he's blending him for more meat.
We're running out.
Alright, into the blender you go.
What did they just...
They should just throw themselves into the blender and then end the day.
where do you get the meat from oh it comes from the right side it'll show up see there you go oh it's actually like the cheat code because we don't have to pay for more meat it doesn't we have to pay for the drugs we put them into the blender oh wait that makes so much and then put him in the grinder too yeah exactly unlimited meat oh you can't put it in the fridge unfortunately the words has gotten around that we suck and nobody's coming no our our yelp review the trimming is so pathetic
yeah no
stuffy wait stuffy wait stuffy there's a dust yeah we got putter and the grinder all right we figured it out right how to play this game after watching the limo tutorial yeah yeah yeah we watched the limo tutorial okay i caught dibs on flipping burgers just like old times yeah yeah we gotta cook it you put them on the thing wait can we pre-make it or like let me check you can pre-make well the burgers will have different like things but you can cook the burgers themselves yeah what yeah I'm wondering if I can pre-cook the meat before uh I think I think it has to open before I okay yeah there you go yeah all right I'm Cook- I'm flipping out burgers!
I'm a good worker.
Oh, I- I got the cooked patties!
Okay, we need three burgers and what the fuck is that?
Cheese?
Is that cheese?
It looks like cheese.
I mean, if it's yellow, it's cheese.
Thanks, cheese.
Also to my chat, is that sound for everybody?
Okay.
I'm making more burgers.
I'm flipping Oh, I gotta cook patty The others don't have cheese
Wait, wait, wait We got three new orders Three patties One and a karmicola.
Yeah, yeah.
Don't worry, I'm cooking more.
Number eight.
We haven't even do number one.
Order number nine.
It's two burgers and some tomatoes.
I got the one.
It's going to be a little louder.
I'll prep the sound a little louder.
Oh, I got more patties.
Don't worry.
I washed my hands.
I'm making order number nine.
Alright, flipping more patties.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
If they said don't come near me.
He'll make an order number one.
Which one's order 10?
Order 10?
Did anyone order number 10?
Number 10, anyone?
Oh, God.
What are we beeping?
Where's 10, guys?
There's no drink for that one.
Number nine, no drink.
Okay, number nine.
Is it number nine?
Are you doing it?
Oh, we're doing it.
We got first happy customer.
Blip-blip-blip-blop.
That's what he said.
Looks different to what I had in mind.
You gave it to the wrong person, Mitt.
You had one job.
No, he said it was wrong.
He said it was wrong.
Are they fighting already?
No, she gave it to the wrong customer!
We're fine, we're fine, everything's fine.
What's order number 10?
Welcome to fast food.
There's more trays here.
this thing wait what order have we done yet and haven't done i'm making i'm making order number uh whatever right now the one on the left oh wait i'll make fries wait how do i burn fries what the fuck oh wait how do you make fries yeah who burnt their fries well that might have been me This is what about him.
This is order number...
I don't think I need to make any more patties.
What's the order set?
Order number 10.
Okay.
There you go.
We have one more order left.
Order number 11.
One patty, two lettuce, and one cheese.
You're going to make order number 11?
No, no.
I'm delegating.
One patty, two lettuce, and one cheese.
Yeah.
You baby!
And then a side of fries.
Our rent is due tomorrow and we covered 14% of it.
Oh.
We're at a 2% net gain for rent.
Um, I don't think we'll be okay.
I got order number 11.
Where did he go?
He's over here.
Alright, hello sir.
Here's order number 11.
Ah!
Wait!
Please say I get paid bit of a wage.
I like this thing.
Is no one going to come into our restaurant anymore?
At all.
Like.
He is tripped.
I'm moving so slowly because I'm almost dead.
Wait, no.
Don't close early.
Maybe someone will come in.
We'll get the...
work at the rush yeah we have rush hour yeah we have we just need four minutes
i love working at sloppies and space guys Oh my god, you guys were like sick That was actually kind of violent This is exactly what's going to pull in the crowd Yeah, yeah, yeah It's like those buskers that put like $5 on their trays It makes it seem like people are donating Why did I see someone orange just walk by in the kitchen?
Wait, what?
There's someone in the kitchen!
Did you see that?
Wait,
what?
Who is that?
Oh my god, it's definitely not.
I think it's over there!
Do you get a dokey doppelganger?
No, it was a mid-doppelganger for me.
Oh!
Oh my god, you just shot him!
It's a mimic.
Oh, it's a dokey.
Yeah.
Oh my god, it's spooky.
Well, make him into pathies.
Yeah, wait, but we couldn't...
Wait, we have a custom...
Oh, wait, never mind.
We don't have a customer.
Never mind.
was a person wait then like when we have been able to make him work for us why do we shoot him he was probably gonna rob us you guys come on yeah he had a suspicious smile yeah yeah i didn't trust him no questions asked i don't understand why doesn't anyone want to come eat at our restaurant i don't know we have such a good aesthetic yeah we even decorated for halloween Queen.
Who's that?
Queen Elizabeth?
It looks like she was bitten by like a werewolf.
Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary.
Don't you fucking...
The new day we might be able to.
That's true.
There's still two minutes left though.
maybe someone will come in like on the last minute and be like i would like five burgers and then we're gonna be rent free yeah you'll tip us for a good service you are gonna what the burgers how do you put them in the freezer oh you just like click on it that's it oh that's not working for me it just tosses the burgers impotently at the ceiling kind of oh it's because it's full all right well i guess i'll just put it here outside the freezer oh you're fine why is the last five minutes of the shift completely empty should we just close up for tomorrow no no the customers will come in the last minute you don't know that still rats downstairs yeah there are yeah we can get rat spiders yeah let's get rid of the rats problem before the health inspector comes in for what it's for what it's worth you could only fire the shotgun once oh okay i know we had a bat Yeah,
there was that lightsaber.
Yeah.
The rats.
Oh, I like that one.
Yeah, there was a lightsaber downstairs.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can just use that.
We can kill the rats in one minute.
Can't be that bad.
Let's kill the rats, rats, rats, rats.
Rats, rats.
Wait, who has the bat, though?
This is for spanking.
Rats.
Wait, there's more tunnels.
Oh, there's one?
Yeah, there's one over there.
Oh, it's not being took the bat away.
Wait, why did she go back?
Oh.
Nice.
Now use that.
That was easy.
Yeah.
Except we only had one shot.
I slipped.
I slipped on rat blood.
Nice.
Alright, I'll get it.
ready to close the day no that that that's snuffy right wait oh that's stuffy's old body yeah yeah that's her old body all right zero i'm closing the day the day's over again are you all ready to start the new day all right day old burgers ready to go okay so yeah i pre-cooked patties You can just put it...
You can just put it...
Yeah, no, it's full right now.
I have a lot of patties.
Wait, how do I... Okay, drop it.
Okay.
I'm a good...
What?
Oh.
Oh, he's not dead.
He's not dead.
Wait.
Oh, no, he's sitting down, though, right?
He is not sitting down.
He is...
Give me a sec.
I'm cooking my patties, sir, before you kill me.
let me be a good worker I just heard a gunshot from five miles away I'm gonna take this order
all right uh one two patties one tomato one pickle two patties oh I'll work on order 14 if nobody is yet doing fries i'm placing a bonnet button oh okay guys dirt i'm i'm two trips away from dying oh wait he heals there's a healing chair we fall yeah it's okay when i die i die i
want to make sure we don't burn it oh wait is that pickle There's a spill, there's a spill, I'm getting the cleanest.
All right, I got, I have all these cooked patties.
There's one on the floor, but it's okay.
Wait, where do I get the tray?
It's still good, it's still good.
It's still good, it's still.
You guys are doing like unholy screens over the damn way patties are?
Um, no, where is it coming from, Snuffy?
I need fries.
I don't know.
My fries on the floor?
I'll take them.
Rumbling time.
Oh, this is a great place.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm delivering 16.
Oh, wait, no, 16.
fries i've got more patties order up order up this is much less complicated than the other game order up more patties they like the food uh we need one comic cola three patties one cheese three patties one cheese what'd you make these out happened they're triple fries they're triple fries are you guys making 15 already no i'm not i'm just watching oh yeah should we clean the trays lock it lock it what did you got a tip oh it's our tip our very first tip i didn't know where to put it we should frame it put it in the jukebox does it work
Is someone making the order?
Yes, Lyme is.
Lyme is the only productive member here.
Lyme is productive.
She's doing the entire order.
It's actually sloppy.
We did it!
We rented due today and we're not making it.
No, no, you don't know that.
The rush order is coming in.
The rush order is coming in, guys.
are you done with that sir oh okay oh yeah he doesn't like that he doesn't like that the customers stop after a while and i'm not sure why i think if we didn't shoot the last customer line move we might have made it i mean he'd already transported you yeah i think it was you know if someone didn't you know Okay,
antagonize the customer and then shot him.
I'm just gonna say, I'm in favor of you.
What happens when the rents do?
We don't pay the rent.
I'm pretty sure we're gonna get lethal company and ejected into space.
There's no way.
There's no way Big Corp is gonna do that to us.
What about this?
This very rare coin.
Wait, can I use it here?
I can use it here.
Oh!
What does it do?
Why are the lights?
freaking out i don't know why did the lights turn off oh wait all i wanted to do was buy dollars
on the the machine because our renters went down by like 20 cents your rent i might have spent money on fries oh i would
go downstairs and turn the power back on i guess so was there power there's definitely not gonna be anything there that will jump me oh so strong it's scary wait do you guys i don't of is because i ate the candy but you guys all sound really weird right now i ate guys i think i'm having a really bad trip right now yes i hate the candy i'm having a really bad trip right now this is not good
oh no
wait what do you see that in the mirror oh do you see it yeah why is it like that yeah why is it why is the snuffy looking back at us oh
did they turn it back what the fair the mirror took snuffy did you guys see that though what happened oh okay that's a glitch that was just really Crazy timing.
Yeah, that's...
What are you doing in there?
Oh.
Oh my god, no wait, you made me!
Shit!
Okay, good.
Update?
I was gonna fix the power and Mario was like...
Hey, what's up?
You know, I'm being like super cool.
Oh, what?
What's going on?
I don't know what's going on.
Wait, someone turned off the gravity.
What is going on?
There's something out here.
Where's the gravity?
Oh.
Oh, it's right here!
Wait, watch this.
Oh, oh!
Oh, that's cool.
I like that.
That's cute.
We all fixed the gravity.
This is a little mini-game.
There's a...
Wait, there's a...
Oh, I think she's having a bad trip.
I think...
Did you eat any candy, Snuffy?
Oh, there is rats!
Wait, they're eating the patties!
I grabbed a rat!
Grabbed him!
Wait, maybe I can...
I'm gonna use...
Oh, shit.
I'm gonna make meat out of these rats.
We did it.
We're gonna kill the rats, yeah.
Alright, I'm gonna kill this rat.
Oh?
Wait, whose body is that?
Oh, shit!
Wait, it was alive?
Ow.
Oh no, I'm one fucking fall away from ending it all.
Wait, why is...
Wait, Lyme died.
Put her in the chair.
Oh, you're right.
I thought you meant the grinder.
Ah!
Okay, I'm still okay.
I still have one more trip.
Alright.
I have one more trip before it's gone.
Yes.
Yeah, I think she tripped and she was not okay.
Welcome back.
What happened?
A ghost spawned in the blackout and killed me.
A ghost bot?
We gotta get the rat.
I'm putting this back.
We already put burgers.
Yeah, is it?
What happened to you leave a bunch of burgers around?
I think, yeah, I think that makes sense.
the space rats don't make sense alien rats guys I think we gotta accept our fate I think the manager is gonna come for us now losing money if the fucking customers stop coming after about three minutes yeah I think we gotta work fast I'm pretty sure so we gotta have a healthy stream of customers I think the I think sloppy I think sloppy court's gonna send in a representative and fire us go bankrupt oh you guys are oh oh oh well burger bots incorporated thanks you for your service as per our contract you signed burger bots incorporated is eligible to initiate a self-destruct protocol installed upon the signing of before mentioned contract should one of the following incidents occur oh we're dying one at a time oh that's fucked up
When repeated complaints received from customers regarding customer service, I keep other disresrupted.
Oh, it's me!
In the industrial espionage being conducted by a single employee working in the same establishment as you.
Sharing the idea.
I refuse or isn't capable of paying for said services tampering with...
One by one.
Love who had to watch us die one by one.
That was a dark, I guess.
All you gotta say is not it, man.
Oh my god.
Oh, well, now we know.
Your diner, you served 16 orders.
67% of the lover orders were acceptable.
Employees suffered 10 casualties.
That's not right.
Yeah.
Yeah, you know what?
No, no, they're right.
What is it?
lives so shoot and die didn't count yeah that's true i think like oh got kicked out we all just got kicked out okay we just got away from the iron to make a new lobby i guess all right but yeah was the sound better now what was i guess like i guess because like the customers didn't die of food poisoning at least that's a win that's a win right i didn't buddy i'm ready for another day at burger bot productive day incoming yeah ready for another day of sloppies and space guys a good worker oh yeah it's true let's do it i'm gonna watch from here but we gotta wait for snuffy though i'll wait for snum snum isn't here yet oh no newie oh wait i know what happened i gotta reset the lobby hold on oh we just get kicked out
all right we gotta wait for the next lobby all right back in it hello I'm back again wait rent covered 12% wait they felt sorry for us it doesn't keep your your settings so it was locked to four players oh oops can you talk hear me yeah we can hear you okay Okay,
yeah, yeah, we just gotta wait for Shnum again.
It should be at five now.
Okay, we wait I think we we can do it this time I believe I like the little random events that happen it makes a little more exciting Yeah, yeah, oh we get in the mimic was I wonder the mimic can talk back You saw like though you were like there's an orange person walking Yeah,
and then like but for me I think like like um if the mimic is like some like is you it changes to a different person it's like i saw i saw mint walking there and i was like what are you guys talking about that's me yeah snuffy needs another invite oh yeah i already invited should be should we get there she is oh there she is hello hello all right let's do that bloody merry thing
Yeah, Nimi.
I want to watch it happen.
I don't know.
I didn't see what happened before.
I didn't see it.
Wait, wait, wait.
You guys are going to die the whole night or whatever.
No, no, no.
They live.
We died from other means.
Yeah.
Yeah, we died.
Yeah, I think we tripped on blood.
Holy shit.
Okay, so that's what happened to us.
All right.
Are you ready to start this?
day my sloppies my sloppy employees no all right we're ready i'm ready to flip these burgers
i'm a good worker a happy worker is a good worker a good worker is a happy worker And Sloppy's Incorporated.
All right, I won't overcook too many patties this time.
Because we don't want the space rats to come in.
Okay, are you making the burger or shall I do it?
Well, one person should...
I'm the burger flipper.
I ain't no burger placer.
Okay, I'm gonna make the burger then.
Oh, wait, was that pickles or lettuce?
Pickles.
I'm making...
This is all I know.
All I know is to flip the burger.
There's some over here.
We take out...
Oh, you make them here.
Oops.
All right, I got more patties.
And I need one more pad.
We're gonna need more...
We're gonna need more patties soon.
I'm gonna do order number three.
All right.
I'm flipping more.
Order number three.
Are you doing two or three?
I was in three.
I'm flipping.
Okay, is that a new logo?
Who drew that new logo?
Wait, we have a new logo.
Yeah, we have a new logo.
Number two coming up.
All right.
I don't know what I can do to assist.
Oh, you can make our draw a new logo.
You're our social media manager, remember?
Alright.
Wait, Snuffy, we need more patties.
Can you go kill an ant for us?
Or kill a customer?
It either works.
Kill a customer.
Wait, I gotta pick up these orders too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, pick it up.
I'm flipping patties.
Patties, really?
We're already out?
Yeah, yeah, we're almost out.
There's two freezer pools worth.
What do you mean?
No, I only have five patties left.
Have you checked both freezers?
Oh, wait, we have another freezer?
When do we have that?
Oh my god, we have another freezer.
Okay.
All right.
I'm cooking more patties.
Order up.
What?
Why does that music sound like a...
Urbanic theme?
Who's doing...
Is someone doing order number six?
I'll get us the comic cola.
No, no one's doing six.
I'll do six then.
I make cola.
Okay.
I'll do seven.
Is it working?
Oh.
Yay!
One more more more more more more more more more more more more.
Nice.
We're recording anything.
All right, I got the soda.
This is the comic soda.
Um...
And then...
Here's some more fries.
And...
Finding number six?
Oh, I got more orders!
Oh my god, wait, there's so many customers coming in!
We're raking in the dough!
Wait, I need more patties!
Seven.
I'm gonna do...
Is someone doing order eight?
No, it's doing order eight.
I'm just flipping my burgers.
My patties.
You can walk.
You can aura walk.
Wait, someone get the cola.
I got the cola.
Alright.
More patties.
Order up.
Oh, that's where I'm at.
Uh, one patty.
One pickle.
I got more patties.
I think that's all we need.
Oh my god, look at.
We're at 62%, guys.
We're doing it.
It's day one.
We're gonna make so many people happy.
Uh, no, we're not.
What do you mean?
Everyone's so happy.
Sloppy.
Oh, our logo changed.
Yeah, yeah, something made...
Our social media manager made a new logo.
Yeah, I can't believe we would do that.
Look, you matter, okay?
Like, even though we're fast food workers, we matter.
I know they just these people have never worked a service job I know They just don't know how to treat anybody Yeah they think just because we're in service That we are lesser than them That's so fucked up It really is man Yeah I think we have a customer I wonder how we keep running I'm gonna get a bunch of rats No no it'll be fun Who cooked all these patties here Okay look no it's fine They only show up on day three.
It's okay.
They'll show up on day...
Wait, what?
Yeah, you can dispose of them.
Dispose of them.
No, wait, don't dispose of them.
The rats aren't even here yet.
We're fine.
When the rats come.
It's okay.
The customers don't know.
Yeah, yeah, they show up on the third day.
It won't hurt them.
is it bad to just call it like I feel like we're only at risk of like weird shenanigans happening we can wait a minute burger meat oh yeah we could find burger meat let's go kill a kill some ants yeah we need to restock I'm running out of patties oh yeah no one time the mirror was showing like snuffy just standing there while yeah we're like oh did the mirror get her like all right we'll watch i'm just here for moral support yeah oh i'll pick that up i'll get it i'll grab it oh oh i thought that was i thought he was down too he looked so dead no i'm okay i'm okay Oh my god,
do you take full damage?
No, no, I thought he was also dead.
I thought you got a double kill.
Is there any more?
Yeah, there's another ant there.
All right, I'll put the patty box in the patty fridge.
All right, patty in the patty fridge.
Maybe the computer.
Patty in the patty fridge.
Oh, nice.
Oh, it just fills up one box.
box only.
I don't know if we can, like, pre-make cola.
Yeah, but rats aren't gonna drink.
They only eat.
Yeah, we need more patties.
We're running out.
I'll change the track.
Oh, it's just there's just one track.
And it's only alien to skill.
That's okay, I guess.
That's all we need.
Alien the skill.
That's all we need in the world.
Hello, everybody.
You guys got more patties?
Oh, my God.
You guys killed so many.
You got so many ants.
There we go.
We got more patties.
Fresh meat.
Oh, you ordered buns?
Where did you order?
Yeah.
You can order more?
Where did you buy stuff?
What?
What do you hear?
I heard rats.
You hear the rats?
Are you okay?
There was no rats?
What do the rats tell you?
Squeaked in the walls!
They're in the walls!
Rats, rats, we are the rats.
They're watching you, Mint.
They're watching you.
They are.
They're watching you look... What are you doing on the PC?
Hmm.
I'm gonna start I'm gonna close early and nine lower buns oh nice that's all we need right oh true I should naturally close a good boss would let us close early that's true yeah yeah it's just more money to pay the employees exactly all right close new day all right ready to lock it in i love working at sloppies in space it's like earth sloppies but in space
i don't got him i got him did you did you get him
yeah yeah that's all he wants all right i got more patties he knows what he wants he's a yeah
comes here every day knowing what he wants all right that should be enough patties right you don't understand sometimes they want four patties on a burger I gotta compensate we get like two customers per day I'm gonna work on order number 13.
I'm making more patties.
What?
She's okay, right?
Well, she exploded.
Well, picked her up.
What happened?
Anyway, back to work.
I'm going to make these burgers.
On the days.
All right, we need one...
What the yellow cola?
I'm going to grab that.
What?
Don't worry.
We got to make sure we make rent before we revive her.
Oh my god.
Make sure we have enough money first.
I have the cola, Freddie.
I have the cola.
I don't even know what... She just started levitating and then she died.
What?
Okay, let's do like two more orders before we raise someone else Wait, I have fries Hit the one and take the orders.
We got them all.
I have cola and fries on the on the front here I'm not even paying attention to anything.
I'm not even doing my job.
I'm back.
I don't even have your blood
Wait the rats are coming.
I hear them.
I hear the rats Wait, I'll take more orders order 17 Save back if you know what's best for all right some customers don't want you close.
Oh, oh she got close to him.
She got close to him Where's the gun?
Where's the gun?
Get the gun.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, they got me me.
Oh, dear Oh, okay, guys guys, we got order up.
We got to make orders Okay, um, oh we used up all the shots.
Okay, you can you can dodge him right?
Okay, I got him I don't got him!
I don't got him!
Okay.
Okay, we gotta put Mimi on the corner so I can walk around here.
Did you- okay, um, we need- Okay, Patty lettuce pick up.
Okay.
How do I do this?
Patty.
Two lettuce.
where's the pickle I'm grabbing you Nimi oh all right and then I wrap and wait did he leave orders up wait he left this guy one of them left oh my god can you work on 15 um um Patty Pat um no I don't know I can do this in time.
Two patties.
Lettuce.
Who's working?
I'm doing 15.
I got 15.
Can someone serve 15 right here?
Yeah, yeah, I got you.
I have the burger and the fries.
Wait, wait, we did put the fries.
We did put the fries.
I'm doing 17.
Fries, fries, fries, I got the fries.
I got the fries.
I flipped burgers.
Alright, I got it, I got it.
I'm flipping the burger.
Guys, we used the 50% of our earnings today to revive.
Don't worry about it, it's fine.
We used 50% of what we made.
I told you guys, we should have left them for dead.
They'll just come back tomorrow for the workday.
Alright.
I am I'm flipping more burgers.
I'm doing 19 All right, I'm flipping more burgers
I'm just saying that we should not spend more money on resin We should let them live with their consequences Wait what happened in the bench?
I'm just gonna want to be a little fast food person I love working at a service job.
All right, I'm making more passes ladies all right look we're back at we're almost back at 60% guys oh my god it's okay I can still flip burgers I don't know I'm still flipping burgers nothing's gonna stop me from coming to work it's all i have okay i'll go i'll go i'll go fry him up
all right now and i'll go if i'm employee of the month guys nothing will stop me from earning five dollars an hour i got i gotta pay my own rent
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
I got the meat.
Oh my god, nice!
Guys, if we'd never serve any future customers from now on, I'm okay with that.
That's fine.
There's a healing room?
No, it's a res room.
Is anyone doing 23?
Wait, we have...
Someone make 23!
Who's working on 20s?
I'll make the cola.
I'll get the cola.
Oh, guys, um, goodbye.
I told you there was something in the room.
That's basic kitchen 101.
There's no 22.
What are you doing?
I didn't realize there was a man above me.
Okay, well, they're just like, all right, 23.
Who's gonna...
Okay, oh, now that I die, I don't get rest.
Okay, I get it.
But Nimi and Stuffy can die twice.
Like...
24?
Okay, I'm fine.
Oh my.
They used up everyone's...
The dresses are shared in the company.
The show must go on.
You're right.
They gotta save money.
I didn't realize vacation days are shared.
Like...
This is this.
Oh shit, yay!
Yay, I get to go back to work in the service industry.
I'm so fortunate.
Okay, I'm making comic soda again.
Comic cola.
Yay.
I have more, oh wait, you guys already did cola.
Wait, I'll put, oh, we need more fries.
Oh, it's raw.
Is anyone making burger 26 and 27?
You're doing 27?
Okay, someone doing 27?
All right, the fries are done.
Here, I got fries here.
You can do 26 if nobody else is.
Yeah, no one else is.
You can't go home.
Two patties, two lettuce for 26.
Two patties, two lettuce.
the fries right here thank you i need orange soda i got orange sodas done orange soda is done okay okay okay yeah yeah yeah you guys need fries we got fries oh we we're quick quick quick it's about to be angry it's about to leave it's about to leave he's getting ready to leave it's true go go go go go yeah lamb you're not making it he's it's god Is he still there?
We just wanted to see the look on your face.
Yay!
Thanks, just what I wanted.
Look, he's having, would you like a dancer too?
Here you go.
Entertainment with your meal.
Yeah.
Woo!
Oh yeah, buy some candy, Snuffy.
On the...
Buy some candy?
Yeah.
Right here.
Wait, why did it laugh evilly?
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I had a really bad trip.
There was a monster in the vent.
You had to, like, look for the goo drops and then shoot the vent that it was in.
Oh.
I said that.
I said, like, a million times to walk under the vents because there's half like one.
Might be with the other.
Wait, what the fuck?
What the fuck did I eat?
Oh, they're worried we're gonna run out.
Hold on.
Well, I'll make some more patties.
Because we're basically out.
Wait, did we stop the day already?
Oh, it is close.
Are you guys ready to start the day?
No, no, no, no, no.
Wait, I'll make more soda.
Oh, wait.
The soda machine stops, too.
Wait, what do we need left?
No, no, no.
It stops when the day is closed, when the restaurant's closed.
We're going to need more.
Are you so tired of hearing?
Oh, no, never mind.
I'm good.
Okay, we need more pickles and lettuce.
Oh, we can order those online.
I'll order your pressure back.
Yay, space Amazon.
Oh, downstairs.
oh yeah we might need more patties can someone shoot a rat i think you might get an order we spent so much money having to rare people to turn to i think we'll be okay we can make 20 of our rent right how do i heal flat soda that's the only way i can drink it oh is that is that the burger i don't know what this is actually oh pickles oh yeah pickles here we need more patties can someone downstairs to someone went downstairs to shoot some things okay that's good because we need that i'm heading downstairs
oh my god i head back upstairs oh there's so much meat i'll go get it nice well you know these are couplets never mind okay i gotta put this i got couplets very good these aren't rats is it okay that we're serving rats to the customers that's fine right like they don't mind that we live in space so it's like not that weird probably yeah that's true that's true we sell our burgers for $3.99 they should know what they're getting that's good they should know exactly what they're getting for $3.99
is it like burgers now like super expensive because inflation there's no inflation in space yeah yeah because I know that nuggies are more expensive now but there's no inflation in space what the candy oh I had a really bad trip when I took the candy like it like yeah it's RNG though it's RNG depending on what candy you get are you trying to get the suspicious candy yeah she is she wants to know what the trip is like
are you okay why the fuck did i why did i get the why did i get the suspicious candy i all right i'm opening up i'm ready to flip the burgers
we got this team all right everybody rise one burger three I'll do it.
Yeah.
We got this.
I'm working on it.
Could you make me a blue soda, please?
Yes, I can.
Thank you.
I am making the patties.
Ooh.
Grub soda sounds pretty good.
Oh, is this raw?
Can't even tell.
Oh, it's not.
All right.
Grub soda right there for you.
Friendly reminder to check your events before you walk under them, guys.
Thank you.
Yep, yep, thanks for the friendly reminder.
Got it.
Alright.
Alright, does anyone have, like, for anyone who doesn't have a task, we're running out of patties again, so someone needs to shoot the rats.
Like, there weren't any down there.
I can go buy something.
Wait, we killed all of it?
How could we have killed all the rats?
We should have left them to run.
reproduce yeah we need to leave too wait oh my god he's going yeah let me give him day old soda he's not gonna tell he doesn't know he doesn't know he's a space Martian how does he know
wait we need more i'm gonna put more fries just in case all right three
yep oh wait is this truck what what kind of fries oh it's raw fries okay nope i think you're good to make it oh order up i'll start with uh i'll start putting the things on the one patty one lettuce one tomato 31 i'll get the fries for you too nimi i'll grab the soda wait i'll grab the orange soda i made the sodas oh you did i made an extra soda okay yeah that's for 31.
oh fries done
But I'll tell you what's 32.
It's three patties, one lettuce.
Three patties, one lettuce.
I'll grab Grub Soda for you.
I love sloppies.
I love working at sloppies.
I love working here every day till I die.
I hope they never promote me.
That's great for you because you're a ghost, so you'll work here forever.
What happened?
It didn't bleed.
Oh gosh, we have so many orders.
Wait.
Wait, I'm dead.
Okay, I'll go get her back.
Wait, who's...
Guys, we still have so many whitenies!
Guys, wait, 29.
I got 29.
No, I'm real, I'm real, I'm real.
I'm real, I'm real, I'm real, I'm real!
Oh, wait, who's that?
What's that?
Where did that guy come from?
He was right next to me.
Oh, what is that?
I'm working on nothing.
I just did 33.
This is 32.
I'm gonna get my fries.
Someone do 29, please.
I wasn't doing 20.
I'll say, okay, it's one patty, one lettuce, and one tomato.
One patty, one lettuce, one tomato.
Oh, oh no.
Oh no.
not this.
Okay, it's fine.
Don't worry, customers.
Just a little oopsie.
We'll fix it soon.
I got the battery.
Woo.
Oh, that's cute.
Alright.
I'm fine.
Sorry.
Go back to your seats, please.
That was just, that was an event.
We are not getting 29.
Yeah, we're not getting 29.
34 is three patties, one pickle.
Is someone doing 34, shall I?
I think you're doing it.
I'm thinking patties.
Okay.
Oh, 29 is about to be over.
Oh, no.
Yeah, I don't think we made it.
I don't think we make it.
I'm currently making order 34.
I'm flipping patties.
Remember, don't walk on to the fence.
Double check the fence.
Okay, 34 is covered.
Yeah, 35 is covered.
I'm doing patties.
I'm working so hard.
Oh, no.
No, not the power.
Guys, I can't flip patties with no power!
We can't even work!
Sir, please.
No, don't leave!
Don't leave!
The power's coming back, please!
Okay, well, one guy left.
I'll do 36!
Someone do 35!
I got 35!
Okay, okay.
I'm on 36, I'm on 36!
I'm cooking as much patties as I can!
I'll get 37!
Less?
38 then.
Uh...
37.
Yeah.
It is.
One burger, one cheese, two pickles.
I'm flipping as hard fast as I can, guys.
Good life.
Which one's done?
Oh.
Oh, I'm hunting.
Oh, someone's air.
Oh, I see him.
He's upset.
Getting the gun, getting the gun.
He's just running around.
Like he owns the place.
It's okay.
I'm still flipping.
Oh, the way I'm still flipping burgers.
Oh, he's doing a little dance.
Okay, it's fine.
I still flipped it.
Hey, guys, we need a...
We need to mop up this blood that's on next to my stove.
Oh, my God, he just dropped the fucking...
I got a rat.
Oh, shit.
I thought he was so alive.
Oh!
The other six freaked out and left.
You gotta kill it, I think.
Okay.
Okay, I have...
The rat.
They're taking my patties.
How do I...
I dispose the rat.
What do you mean by the worry?
Who is that?
Who is blue and walking around really slow?
That's suspicious.
That's me.
Oh, okay.
Okay, that's just me.
You were suspicious.
Whoa.
Okay, where's the...
mob.
I almost died for real.
Wait, we, guys, guys, we got someone work on 38.
We need to work on 38.
I took another order too.
Oh my god, there's another rat.
Where's the, where's the mob?
Where did the, where's, oh my god.
Where is the mob?
I'm fucking slipping on everyone's blood.
Oh my god, please.
Not again.
No!
Stop taking the patties oh god get over here stupid rat no okay i'm fine i'm fine oh my god i burnt my patty i fucked up 38 i get it on 39 okay okay it's fine i have one trip away but it's fine who has some up there's no buns left oh god oh god oh god i'm gonna i'm gonna take his order
How can we be out of buns?
Oh my god.
We just end the day.
Just end the day.
We just fucking.
We did it.
I'm closing the shop.
The shop somewhere.
Leave.
Get out of here.
We.
Oh wait.
What the fuck?
There's a dead customer here for some reason.
How did he die?
All right.
Into the grinder.
into the if we grind the bodies there's no evidence so they can't get us yeah we gotta buy buns and everything okay maybe we should have i paid the rent oh nice okay maybe we should have accepted more customers before i close the shop it was just a lot you know it was it was a lot and we finished rent i'm not i can't run anymore wait if i okay i'm gonna throw myself wait i need guys
guys i'm gonna throw guys i'm gonna throw myself in the grinder so i can respawn for the next day because i'm one slip bad slip away wait you can you can just heal no no it's wait but doesn't that take money money wait not for healing oh wait how do i heal are you sad where oh okay no it took ten dollars it took ten dollars no no no no that was already down oh okay i'm pretty sure yeah you're good you're good yeah i spent ten dollars on tomatoes because we're running out of food oh okay yeah i'm getting better did we get buns i'm restocking wait but you guys could have used my body for more to pay for patties no the people don't make patties unfortunately we are robots oh oh we don't we're not real wait what we're robots we're ai we got a bunch huh there's no gluten free in in space i'm sorry to tell you that
It's all glued in in space.
What's our logo now?
Is it still the same?
I think it's the same because we started on the same day, yeah.
Vaga, sloppy.
Welcome to sloppy.
Are you ready to start the day?
Are you ready?
All right.
Get to work.
Where's Limo?
I was grabbing ingredients.
All right.
I flipped the burger.
We have refilled the tomato.
And yay.
the patty I have a cook patty for you concert I need three um well you gotta be fucking patient I am patient all right all got porn patties be your Oh, could someone get the Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh Oh, oh, oh, oh my god, oh my god What the, oh, oh,
oh, she dead She's dead No, my bird patty Where's my Yeah, there goes our customer God damn Oh, shit I tripped I tripped my mouth Oh my god.
It's okay.
She's stuck too.
Wait, I got you.
I got you.
I hate this game.
You can only watch.
Oh shit!
No!
We don't have enough money to raise her!
Oh shit!
Everything is not okay.
Oh my god, my patty!
It's okay.
Oh no, my patty.
I'll take our order Oh my god, we gotta make money so we can bring Limeo back Um, okay Okay, Nimi, you tell me what I have to do for this order Oh, I can't see We can't see It's fine, it's okay, everything's fine Three patties Um It only gave me It's okay,
we're okay, everything will be fine everything will be fine okay and that's all mock-up we're wait where's the trays oh there's the tray where are the other two where's the other two employees i'm doing uh the first one this is 49 where's 49 wait where's 49 49 are you wait how do i know 52 53 wait where's 49 please i'm please please please oh
wait how did you do that how did you do that realize that you're in death's chat it's just nimi and she can't move oh i can't wait
going so good wait what happened you want to run it back one more time yeah we're gonna do one more time wait how did yeah we try one more time wait how did you two die i got killed by a hooker that's sprinting around in the doorway yeah i know how you died line but what about min and and snuffy how did you two do it still just running free i think i watched snuffy try to shoot him and maybe miss and then he should have killed his boss I see,
I see alright, restarting the lobby Alright, we just gotta wait for the one customer I don't even know how that customer died I think I had a heart attack or some shit I don't Like what happened Okay, the one bullet is like Pretty rough for us I feel like I know everyone I feel like we should have the bat upstairs so we can have a just in case you know you can buy more bats as well if you want yeah i'm gonna whoa what did you guys hear that yeah did you hear a dog sorry that was my dog oh that was your thoughts like space dog i'm gonna grab the bat okay
guys i have a bat just in case something happens oh b okay you you can trip over on the bat just as an fyi oh okay i'm gonna put it right here then That is worse.
That's not very convenient.
That's where I put the bat.
Just in case.
Are we all ready to start our day?
Yep.
Alright.
Because I don't think we need Mint anyway.
Because she's doing our social media right now.
She's like the Wendy's of our restaurant.
The Wendy's Twitter.
One, two burgers, one pickle.
Alright.
I'm grilling.
grilling with love make sure make sure to put a smiley face ketchup ketchup smiley face when it's done
feeling burgers from your thing sorry all right here is more patties oh
patty is getting ready on this side oh that's not what i wanted i'm gonna do order three this
is my purpose this is all i need to know i just flipped the burger flipped the patty and everyone was happy
uh i'm gonna have more patties for us
I want to work on order number four.
We got more patties for us.
Here's your tray for order four.
Thank you.
We got more.
All right, and then...
All right, we need more patties.
I'm running out.
I think you know what to do.
It's time to go to the basement.
These guys are actually terrifying on us.
All right.
There I go.
Okay, I'm taking order number five unless someone else does.
I don't think anyone's making five.
I see Mimi's making soda.
I'm making soda.
Who's doing order number six?
Anybody doing six?
Nope, nope.
That's your job.
Okay, I'm doing six.
I'm doing six.
I got the tray for six.
All right, I go get more patties.
I'm going to do a hard job right now.
All right, I have the guy.
I'm gonna shoot some rats.
Don't worry.
I gotta shoot some rats.
Where's the rat?
Oh.
Oh, that's very far.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, I missed.
Oh, shit.
Okay, this is bad.
Okay.
I guess we won't have more patty
oh that's awkward um so we're recharging um so bad news i shot a rat and the rat's body went flying so like i couldn't get it
i'm working pre maybe pre we might need more soon so maybe make some more fries there is no five i'm doing eight we're doing okay i'm gonna work on five all right i'm doing more making more patties anybody got order nine no no order nine okay snap me on nine i'll do ten all right i'm getting us more pat i'm i'm cooking more patties why is it so raw okay oh my gosh Did you wear gloves?
Wait, were you, did you wear gloves or not?
Were you protected?
I need an orange.
Is that orange?
Fry's done, Fry's done.
But it's first got a drink.
It's glued down now.
More patties coming in.
More flip patties.
Bye.
This is, this is where I got in my life.
Little blue.
And I'm on the side.
do we need more i think we i think we're fine with the oh this is like a patty that's raw forever it is not cooking at all wait wait what happened to the computer monitor what wait i think we're done wait we're done we made our rent already by the way i'm just gonna pay it no no wait we can pay no no wait we can wait we can farm money and then like pay uh like stockpile it for the next sure yeah yeah yeah as if anybody else comes home exactly wait mint mint mint can y'all look at you real what the what you see that I'm worried about me too I think she has a rough life out I think she might have a rough home life right now what are you talking about what are we saying No,
no, no, no.
No, no.
No, we're here for you.
We're, we're here for you.
We're-
That doesn't mean you can't have feelings.
Yeah, yeah.
We're all here for you, man.
If you, exactly.
Man, look, you might need a look in the mirror, man.
I think, I think you might have tripped some, some time ago.
Yeah, I think I think you should look in the mirror This is how I woke up
Do you think we have insurance from this job?
I don't do you think we have health benefits?
Wait, I can't get up guys Guys Oh, wait, I got up.
Oh, I was looking at the offset the vibe so i'm a lobby employee wait we can change it wait i didn't realize you could change wait you could just make your own face yeah
oh i do this is so sad oh what are you wait can you see it wait look at me look at me Is it just a blank?
Is it just a, oh it's just a, it's just a void, right?
Is it just a void?
I feel inside working to serve his job.
If I could rebrand into anything that I ever wanted, what would I ever want to be?
What would you want to be?
That's a good question.
Yeah.
Mimi, you can try.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Mimi, you should change your...
You should get plastic surgery.
We all did.
Hey, hey.
Oh, I know.
Yeah, I'll go after.
What the fuck?
I can't.
God, you're so scared, though, Keith.
It's how I feel working every day.
It's how I feel working every day at Sloppy's.
Now, now I'm going to have to, like, I'm going to accidentally shoot one of you because I don't know your things anymore.
I'm smiley.
loves working at Sloppy's.
Tell us how much you love Sloppy's, Snuffy.
Oh, I messed up.
I love Sloppy so much that I spend every day of my life here.
You can redo, you can redo it, yeah.
Oh my god, I love how it's on the walls, it's...
Yeah, oh yeah, I see, like, Mint's logo.
That's Sloppy.
It's Sloppy.
Yeah, is it?
sloppy and fireworks no it's how she feels every day working at sloppy's look how happy she is look she's smiling smile just like smiley wait we're smiley oh there's check in the perimeter wait what is neemie's face oh beautiful All right, well, I wonder what Lymo's gonna make.
All right, Lymo.
Mimi, how do you feel working at Sloppy's every day?
What was that?
Does anybody hear, like, a scary piano?
No.
I think that's just disco, alien disco music.
We only have one track in our jukebox.
It's just alien disco.
This is an absolute classic, you guys.
If you play Alien Disco, then like...
Yeah, what do you love about Alien Disco?
Smiley?
I love that it plays non-stop and repeat.
Gotta dance.
Day is over.
Yeah, we did.
But we could stockpile our money for for the the other days so i feel like we should just keep going instead of paying rent yeah we can buy weapons wait we can't yeah oh yeah we can buy more bats lightsabers
oh what was that oh she was bloody marrying she was sorry i was i was I was having a smoke break in the bathroom.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're bloody high.
Oh, shit.
Your girlfriend?
Wait, you... Wait, she said yes?
She just stabbed me.
No, we're not at that level yet, but she just doesn't know it.
Oh, that's y'all, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you're just that...
You'll get her.
She said that I have a dead end job, but like...
gonna you're up for that promotion though aren't you that's good that's good I love your face it's so good yeah don't get his map of face don't get no I I had a face but use black on black I see it looks like the fucking hey who turned out the lights thing and doctor who It's a fucking great idea.
Hold on.
Wait You need to do like a black background and then a skull Have you ever watched the one with David Tennant and then he re reincarnated and I was like not my doctor Yeah, they always do that.
Yeah, that's how they do it Yeah, yeah, but yeah, but that was my line.
I was like, not my doctor.
Get out of here.
I think there was at least one or two that were like notable, right?
How many bathrooms?
11?
No, they're at like 15.
Yeah, they're at 15 already.
Is David Tennant the one with the Fez?
Or do they all have the...
No, that's the one after.
Is it Matt Smith?
Yeah, that's Matt Smith.
He's in Game of Thrones.
David Tennant's the one that like everyone obsesses over and he came back.
Yeah, because he's the one that sang the walking song.
I forgot what it's called.
Okay, did you see when he came back?
500 miles.
Yeah.
And I will walk a hundred miles and I will walk a hundred more.
And I forgot what that is.
That's already, that's a different company song.
We have Asian disco.
Yeah.
Oh,
oh, oh, I thought she had a dented head or some shit.
I thought she like fucking gets like the headphone dead or some shit.
Oh, no.
Oh.
All right, I'm making a patty.
Yeah, dented snake.
I never stop cooking.
I always cook.
Oh my god, hope my patty's don't burn.
I might have put too many patty's on the grill, guys.
Order number 22.
Who's doing 22?
I got 22.
I got a lot of burgers.
22.
Oh my god, I have so many Has anyone listened to the new Taylor Swift songs?
I heard like I heard it's bad because she's happy now Yeah, because like yeah because people were saying oh it's because she's happy now and that and like happily make being happily married So your songs don't aren't the same Yeah, you're like it's kind of
Thank you two birds I don't think we need, I don't think I need a grill anymore patties.
That's a lot of patties.
Yeah, where's the pain and angst, exactly?
This job is easy.
Yeah, until they start trying to kill you.
That's where it gets harder.
Oh.
Oh my god, he's just mad.
He's not even that scary.
Oh, shit!
Wait, that's not...
That's a different...
That's a different man.
I know, someone should!
Please!
He's right behind me.
Hold up.
You got this, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hold up.
We need black.
Oh, shit.
I keep tripping.
I keep...
Okay, I got this.
I got this.
Watch this.
Whack!
I told you.
guys she's not dead he's not dead guys he's just stunned oh wait he doesn't die wait what do you mean he doesn't let me see no no wait i'm alive i'm not alive i'm not alive he just he just sniked me from across the book in rooms we don't wait do we have a gun oh my god okay need me You okay,
okay.
Is he still out there?
Yeah, he's still out there.
That's a gamer.
Wait, wait, you still died?
Uh-oh, wait, wait.
Oh, no.
Oh, my two!
I think because Snuffy the Snuffy died in the kill machine.
Wait, but is Is Nimi still alive?
Do you want me to reset it?
Wait, I don't know if Nimi...
Wait, oh Nimi, did you die?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh!
Nice, nice.
Everyone except me.
Okay, let's get alive.
It's getting loud.
Yeah, he's still out there.
He's still out there.
I don't think we can kill him.
Guys, remember when we had a hundred percent done and now we're at 63 you remember he's gone he's actually dead he's gone oh dang it i did it again hold on i got you i got you guys no all their customers are leaving yeah we're kind of booked no we take their order take their order She wiped this out.
Oh wait, what?
There's another- Where's the mom?
Oh no, I heard screaming.
Oh, who's getting revived now?
Sorry, I was in- Wait, what about me?
Why is- what about me?
There's a- there's an imposter.
There's a- There's an imposter out there.
Oh wait, really?
There's an imp- I'm gonna get in the heat.
But then, oh, Baka, wait.
Wait, is that the imposter?
What the flipping?
Wait, wait, we just walked past the imposter.
What?
What is the night before you do the pumpkin?
You need to sit here for five seconds.
Wait, come on.
Oh, wait, there's my dog.
I will feed my dog.
Oh my god.
Wait, how did you die, Snuffy?
There was an imposter.
Oh, so it was the mimic that got you.
Yeah.
Someone is still able to move around.
Did we all die to the imposter?
Yes.
No, there was a fucking sniper in the bed.
There was a sniper?
There was a sniper.
Oh.
Maybe we should have just paid our rent.
We got too greedy.
We got so greedy.
I think we learned our lesson.
I think we can do.
I think we can make it.
Okay, we can make it.
We can make it.
Yeah, yeah.
Last game.
Look, it wasn't our fault, guys.
There were three people trying to kill us.
Like what were we supposed to do?
Like...
Like it was day two!
What the fuck?
It was day two!
How the fuck were we supposed to know there were gonna be three killers?
What was that?
Yeah, Doki, what happened to me?
Is the... I heard you scream.
I turned around and said, is that a scream important?
And then a red light scanned across the room and shot me down what the fuck come up from like the ceiling i think it was that yeah jesus it was like an automated gun or something oh my god there's like snipers now in the fucking vent bro it was day two but we don't utilize it oh someone designed a logo yeah someone designed a logo.
We ain't being, we're not burger bots.
I'm making my face.
I'm making my face right now.
I'm surprised this, oh wait, we're working.
Wait, but what about our logo?
It's okay.
First day's easy.
We'll be fine.
Okay, okay.
I'm grilling.
I'll get order one, three birds.
I'm doing the one thing I'm good at.
I'm starting, oh, oh, oh, there's buns on everywhere.
There's buns everywhere.
Wait.
Order two.
Buns, buns.
Okay, okay.
Paddies.
I can do either.
They're both three bergs.
Yeah, three bergs.
Paddies are coming in hot.
Coming in hot.
It's burning my fingers.
Grabbing it with your fingers.
I put my face on.
Order two in the middle.
All right.
I'm grabbing more paddies.
I'm doing order three.
Okay.
Order one and three are being worked on, right?
All right.
cooking more patties for us.
Okay.
Gosh, I love when they say plop, plop, plop.
I'm so happy.
What if that's like a slur?
It's an alien.
You don't know, do you speak their language?
Plop, plop, plop.
Everybody, it's fries.
I'm working on order four.
I'm getting your fries out for everybody.
All right.
Order four.
Okay, okay, okay.
all the patties here.
I'll get more patties on the other desks now.
I'll do order five.
More patties coming up.
Coming up hot.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oops, they won't know that it was on the ground.
Yeah, they can't see the kitchen.
We got more orders.
Five is three.
Okay.
Alright, order up.
Alright.
Order 6.
I think that's enough patties, right?
Do we need more patties or am I allowed to stop?
No, we're fine.
We're fine.
Don't waste more.
All right, all right.
I'm gonna wait for these three.
We're gonna need a restocking patty soon.
Maybe do some murder while we got a backlog?
No, I'm gonna... I'm gonna redesign my face.
That's more important.
all right
how i feel working every day at sloppies what what happened did you get a bad candy are you okay no she's having a trip right now she's having a fucking trip now you know how it feels yeah yeah i could get the Oh, yeah, you got the fries.
Nice.
Yeah, I got them.
Create for order eight.
There you go.
Oops.
Oh, wait.
I can hold two?
I have two hands.
Oh, my God.
If you right-click, left-click, you can hold two patties.
If someone made me the drink for nine, oh, my God.
I have two hands.
It's like I have two hands or some shit.
This changes everything in the patty-making business.
Big the Discovery.
Thank you!
Uh-huh.
I'm dual wielding.
That's nine, right?
Wait, we got another customer.
Yeah.
I got him.
I'll start it on a drink for him.
I'll order him, I'll cook more patties because we're running out again.
Oh my god, the dual wielding changes the fucking meta.
Oh my god.
I- I'm working on him.
I'm working on him.
All right We need someone to kill some rats downstairs because we're like running out of patties Yeah, but I was Yeah, but we're saving it for day two Imagine how Imagine how efficient it'll be it'll just be one rat.
I can grab him I can grab the rat Blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip.
Did we do it?
It's worth slumping.
How did we get 100% last time?
Like, where the fuck are our customers?
I'm like...
I picked somebody off, though.
Like, I actually made them mine.
Wait, well, how did you make him mad?
What did you do?
He said that's not what our...
Yeah, I mean...
They just aren't appreciative.
I guess we have time to redesign our faces while we wait for customers.
Oh yeah, we need a logo.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stephanie, make the logo.
There's so many patties.
It's fine.
They just ended the day and then did it again.
Oh, fresh for tomorrow?
Yeah, it'll be fresh for tomorrow.
It's made of outer rats, so like...
It's made out of rats, so it's fine.
So it's fine, yeah.
They have like...
42-hour expiry date.
Fucking first, Dookie.
He looked like the whole supply.
No, we still have seven patties left.
That's fine.
Dookie was yelling at everyone, being like, oh, shoot, more patties.
More patties.
Oh, it's our logo.
Can't be Burger Bunch.
We're franchising.
I think it should be a little rat.
Oh, that's true.
Do you guys remember how long, like, food can be at, like, or meat can be at room temperature before it becomes a biohazard?
We're in space.
It's always cold in space, so it should be fine.
It has rat preservatives on it.
We're fine.
But it also attracts the actual rat.
That's why the rats want the patties back.
They're trying to bury the dead.
Oh, that's it.
You know how like, you know, they did those video science videos where like, um, they test out how fast fast food rots and the burger takes like, yeah, yeah.
In space, it never rots.
I'm ready for the next day if you guys are.
Because of our rat preservatives.
All right.
Wait, I need Sophie's designing our logo.
We should let her finish.
Okay.
Momu's done.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
Yeah, I want to see our, we're rebranding because we weren't doing so hot last time.
So we got rebranded.
We got to rebrand the restaurant so they don't know where the other one.
Oh, dance on that patty.
Wait, are you doing the Burger King foot lettuce?
Number five, the Burger King foot lettuce.
There are food inspectors in space, so it's fine.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, we're okay.
God, there's two whole vats of fries just fermenting as well.
I mean, we could just put it up here.
Yeah, we just put it in a microwave and we'll be okay.
Yeah.
That's what the microwave is for.
We got our logo.
Let's go.
What does it look like?
Oh, wait, that looks so good.
Wait, look at our logo.
Look at our logo, guys.
I think we can end the day.
Look at our logo.
Look at the logo.
It's a rat burger.
It's a sloppy burger.
Here they come.
I got order 11.
I got patties.
We don't need more patties.
What if they order five patties?
That's our entire stock.
Ever since I learned a dual wield, it changed the whole game.
Change the whole system.
All right.
Wait, Fry's done.
Fry done.
We're showing 11.
Wait, I'll do the other soda.
I have the soda done.
Thank you.
Soda done.
Two and two pick.
Top done.
Thank you.
Rise here too.
We're getting two orders.
Hello, hello.
Thank you.
I got another cola.
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
There's a bag.
Oh, wait, wait.
Get the gun, get the gun, get the gun.
Mid, mid, careful.
He's looking at you.
Okay, no, he's, that's fine.
Um, I'll grab the soda.
Okay.
I'm getting ready.
Was he number one on the floor?
Oh, no.
No.
I got the soda, though.
Oh, oh, wait.
He's just dead.
All right.
I got the orange soda.
Yeah, we got more customers.
One patty, three lettuce.
I got number.
I got order for...
Oh, you got 14?
I got 15.
We're going to need...
We need more buns soon.
Someone doing 15, or should I do it?
Oh, I'm doing 15.
You can do 16.
I'll do 16.
Oh, you're doing 16?
Alright.
Pickle.
Lettuce.
How many lettuce is that one?
Alright.
And then make sure to draw a smiley face with ketchup.
Wait.
I messed with order 16 out.
I gave a pickle instead of lettuce.
This is mine then.
Yoink.
Wait, am I 15?
I'm 15.
Oh, where's the 15th guy?
Hello, sir.
I got your order.
Flip-flop.
Goodbye.
New order.
Order up.
17 going out.
Wait, do we need more patties?
Oh my god, wait, we need more patties, guys!
Why did you make me stop?
What?
Look at that!
We're running out of patties!
Is someone doing 18?
No, I meant like grilling.
Okay, I'll wait.
I'm grilling.
I'm grilling What is that noise?
What is that noise?
Yeah I'm doing 19 could someone grab the mop someone's plorted all over the place.
Oh, no
Not plorting all right two one pickle one one lettuce I got more patties Why do I keep hearing weird noises?
I hear it too.
It's like air conditioning Somebody in the vents.
Oh, it could be that.
Oh, nice, nice patty.
Wait, I gotta...
I already got more...
My vision's all distorted, which probably means bad is happening.
What's distorted?
Her vision.
I've noticed when something weird is happening, my vision goes a weird in game.
Oh, you got the manager vision.
It's the vents.
It's the vents, you guys.
Don't walk under the vents.
There is something in it.
Wait, how do you know?
Where is he?
There's goop.
Oh, yeah, there's goop over there.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I see it.
Yeah, he's just there.
I don't think it gets killed by the gun.
No, you just got to shoot it.
Oh, I tried.
I didn't like that.
Yeah, you move.
Just have hot aim.
Dang it.
Boop sucks.
All right.
What can you hate working here, bro?
We got, is anyone working on Order 19?
I got the soda for it.
I got those tears.
grub soda we all gotta start somewhere no answer 19 but i have the soda already oh my god we have so many orders many orders i got grub soda again too i just heard somebody like gosh all over the place did somebody die oh yeah liamu killed killed the vent man thank god
I'm getting the fries.
I have the soda all done.
I did 19, I did 19.
Alright, I'm gonna take this guy's order.
I'm gonna wait until you guys...
I'm gonna wait, actually.
Because I don't know if he's like the one that doesn't like it when you're near him.
and then you do find 20.
where's 19?
you find 19.
they're gone.
where's 19.
oh the fries are done oh you got the fries okay all right i'll make more patties 22 is nobody doing 22.
no i don't think so no one's doing any orders right now i'll do 24.
oh what's that doing 25 and let someone That's the bed man's sound.
He sounds like air conditioning.
Doing 25, tomato, two cheese.
I'm doing 22.
I'm giving you guys patties.
I'm doing patties.
I'm on 25.
We're so efficient guys.
We're a well-oiled machine.
Look at us.
We're calling our orders out.
We're doing this.
Yeah, we're doing that.
You need to reorder some supplies, I think.
I need fries and...
we need more patties we're running out again oh we are definitely out we're out out we're out we have four patties left careful the vent the vent man is back he's gonna make you pay the vent troll
you hear that someone's grunting you hear that right maybe they're killing the ants he's like what is anyone on 26 I don't think so
Okay, then Did I- Did my order expire?
I don't think so What's your order?
I don't- I think it- I didn't expire.
Yeah, because you had a drink on you.
I don't know.
I think I'm crazy.
Alright, I'll get the drink for her.
We're gonna need more cups soon too.
We only have seven left.
Alright, I have the drink.
I have the drink for 27.
I'm doing 27.
Alright, someone do 28.
I also need more patties.
I have four patties left.
Oh, I was 27.
I think I made this one, yeah.
I wasted so much stuff.
I hear someone talking in the bathroom.
Who's having a bathroom break right now?
There's no breaks at Sloppies.
We work until we fucking die.
28.
I don't think so.
I'm 28 then.
They're so rich.
What?
Oh, nice.
Are you good?
Were you like wrapping to yourself, miss?
Do we get everything?
Wait, do we have any special?
We have a special coins!
My turn.
Oh, yeah.
What's this one?
Oh.
Oh, everything seems okay.
Oh, what do I buy another candy?
Yeah, everything seems okay.
What?
Where?
How so?
Look at it.
Okay, what?
Oh, wait.
No, the drink is just keep going.
It doesn't stop.
It's not...
Do we...
that for me oh i fixed it i fixed it i fixed it you just got press the button again he just got whack it we need more than soda lids by the way turn it on and off yeah turn it on and off and it'll fix itself we definitely need more patties we're a little for sure running out
we always need more patties oh my god that's a lot okay i got the tomatoes all
right i gotta restart i'll deliver i got the tomatoes we're doing so well now we've learned oh oh back to work new day no breaks at sloppies we work until we die because we love working at sloppies i'm doing the first one i'm doing it i'm doing it i'm doing it i'm doing it believe in myself enough to brew one one burger wait we don't have anyone like coming in the haunted cloud music no what what do you hear we hire the mascot performer i don't think i don't think we did did we maybe it's somebody's birthday we do like birthday parties right no are the waiters all being done right now Is someone doing orders?
Yeah, we just finished an order.
Which ones are called?
Do I need to do any?
I need to.
When we saw one.
38.
There's only 30.
Yeah, where did the 38 come from?
I was like, 30.
Okay, I'm doing 31.
I was like, am I fucking blind?
Like, where is that?
It looks like there.
Mint is so efficient, she's making burgers in the future.
Yeah, she's like, she's making...
What?
Well, what's on order 38?
Mint, what did you see in the future?
What am I doing 32?
Oh, 38, we developed a new meat.
Oh, we're not using rats anymore?
What happened?
I was gonna use one head.
Rat free!
But it gives the extra zest, though.
I'm doing 33.
If my burger doesn't have rat in it, I don't want it.
Wait, guys, we actually ran out of patties.
We haven't run out until the inside are used.
I used both fridges, guys.
I know when I'm out.
Doing 31.
Or 33, even.
Sorry.
Oh, okay.
Alright, I'm gonna go downstairs to see if there's more meat.
I'm going downstairs to check for supplies.
No rat, no burger.
Oh, we got buns, though.
Uh, so we ran out of patties, guys.
Wait, that's rats stealing my fucking patty!
Oh my god, he disappeared.
What are you talking about?
We ran out of patties.
The rats are here.
Okay, let's kill one of the customers.
We need patties, and I don't want to waste our money.
No, can we just go kill a...
Kill a what?
Do the rats respond?
They don't.
You good?
No.
You can shoot him.
You shoot him?
There's two here now.
Yeah, we're good.
all right uncle get more meat gonna put this gun back up to charge yeah in case we have an angry customer
why don't we eat rats like what's wrong with their meat I guess because they did start the plague right we don't want another plague
all right I got the patties
wait guys someone take the customers or Pretty.
I'm in.
Oh, you got it?
You go, you go for it.
Someone just tossed a tray at us.
All right.
We're getting more patties for us.
Is someone on 36?
I don't know.
Okay, I'm on 37.
Oh, you're on 37?
Okay, I will do 30.
I will do 38.
Oh my god.
Oh, oh, oh, the power's coming up.
The power's coming off.
I got it.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
That means...
my patties won't burn.
This isn't good.
I'm tripping on candy.
What do you see?
What do you see when you're tripping on candy?
There's no...
Watch it!
Oh, I think someone died.
No.
Oh, he's dead.
He's dead.
Oh, but she's dead too.
She took him down with her.
Wait, okay.
Two...
I'll take her's order.
Oh, that's a good worker right there.
Don't worry.
I'll go make more meat out of him.
Thank God.
We were running out of two.
We needed more supplies.
Thank God he was angry.
Yay!
More patties.
That's why I like the seed.
I wonder what she was seeing.
She was tripping on some.
I wonder what that was like.
They
just shot one of our customers.
Wait, what?
They just shot Mint.
Wait, our customer shot her?
What did she do?
No, no, the TV keeps shooting people.
If you can make the orders, I'll keep an eye out for the TV.
Oh, okay.
Um, two patties, two...
Oh, wait, it's here.
Two patties and a fry.
Okay.
Wait, we have no buns left.
I can't do anything.
Yeah, we have no buns.
They're coming up.
So he's getting them.
Okay.
Yeah, because we can't do any orders.
What's going on in here?
It's okay.
Five.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, I think it's burning.
Oh, well.
Oh, I...
One on the left.
One on each.
Oh.
No.
Don't.
You didn't.
Oh.
What?
Order two, Seth.
It should be okay.
Okay.
One patty.
One.
I'll do 39 right now.
screen anymore is it good i think it's good yeah i think we're fine was that a person was that a ghost two pickler okay plunge it back plunge it back all right i'm holding two pickler someone hurry and do a 38.
this is 38 fun yeah i do i'm doing 39 right now yeah 38 fun 38 that's 38 i need a tray oh wait stat i got a tray it's fine I need, oh, it's dripping.
Wait, I can't do soda.
Wait, unless I can do soda.
Do I get him?
Guys, we have no more lids.
We have no more lids.
Order some lids.
Why do I need 38 lids?
I'm going to do 42.
I'm doing 40.
Oh my god, please.
My fries.
I'm doing, I did 39.
39 39 please don't leave please don't leave sir we're 39 46 52 no don't leave i don't know where 39 is 44 43 49 wait the 39 left oh
my god no 39 left wait what no he's still here wait why are there two people that
Okay, it's okay, it's okay, I got it.
I have two hands.
She's not dead, she's alive.
No worries, everybody.
I'm not dead.
Everyone return to your seats, guys.
Oh, shit!
Are you dead?
No, I'm alive.
I'm real, I'm real.
It's a bug, it's a bug.
I'm not gonna save this because I'll get attacked.
There's a vent, there's a vent.
Be careful, don't walk under this guy, Loki.
Okay.
Can you see me?
I can see you, Mint.
Did someone get the leg?
Wait, there's another, there's another ventman.
Oh, guys, oh this is not good.
I'm gonna pay our oh, this is not good.
Guys, guys, I don't think we're all alive.
It's okay, we're good.
It's cool.
Yeah, but they don't.
The orders, they're all expired.
They're all expiring They're all leaving I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry What if we just close up?
What if we just close up?
They're all leaving.
They're all mad
Okay, um, I don't know what we're supposed to do.
I'm so confused Oh the day's over yay We disappointed everyone!
Yay!
Okay, we gotta restock.
We have to restock, guys.
We are running out of.
We're running out of...
What do we need?
Lids, lids, lids.
We're running out of lids.
I ordered lids.
That's the only thing we're running out of.
It wouldn't let me use the computer.
That's weird.
Yeah, I can use it.
Uh-oh.
Another job badly done.
If you're expecting five star service at fucking sloppies, you're in the wrong neighborhood.
You're in space, ma'am.
Oh.
What?
What happened?
That's me.
Okay, okay, you're here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where are you guys looking at?
Never rest.
Everything's fine, you guys.
Everything's fine.
Everything's fine as sloppy.
Are we good to go?
Do we have our lids yet?
Yeah, we do.
I've got cubs.
We got everything restocked.
I'm starting to work, Dave.
The day is over.
Wait, what?
I thought it was already over.
Yeah, I thought it was already over.
Alright, a day...
Wait, we didn't get lids.
We didn't get lids.
Oh, we didn't get lids?
Oh, shit.
Okay, well, maybe they won't order a drink.
Um, where's your order?
Um...
Uh...
Oh, you're doing so...
That's...
Not good?
Guys, what did they order?
This is a bad dokey!
What?
No, I'm here!
Okay, I need...
Oh, that's so dumb.
Wait, which one's the bad dokey?
Oh my god, thank god.
God, you made the right choice.
I was wondering who she was going to shoot.
Yeah, we're going to make food.
That's such an important question.
Guys, I think we've...
Wait, you can read it?
The first order is two burgers.
All right, well, I guess only Live will can make the orders.
None of us can read it.
They're completely invisible.
Me too.
I'm gonna put more pat.
I'm gonna fucking make more meat
Bye, we have bun box.
Oh, it's that fry bag box.
Oh, we oh we don't even realize we ran out of fries Oh, my god.
Are you real?
Are you real next to me?
Please tell me you're real.
Oh, oh, you're real.
Oh, don't Oh, don't stop because I tripped on the meat!
Oh, I'm okay now.
I'm okay.
Alright, I thought I was a mimic.
Oh, my God.
Alright, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Alright, I got you.
I got more patties.
What?
Oh, good.
Wait, it was just two?
Oh, wait, there you go.
Oh, my God.
can't reach it oh my god what are these budget cuts need fries need orange can i have orange soda please i'll bring whatever this is too my god we're cutting corners left and right
yeah there's cheese it's all right nice this is cooked i don't want to stock the cheese who Not me.
We don't even need cheese.
Why didn't we buy all this cheese?
We're prepping.
It's called meal prep.
I still can't see the monitor, so I don't know who's making our burgers for us.
It's only one person can see the monitor and she's not here.
But where did Limeo go?
She's literally the only one that can see the monitor.
Where is she?
Yeah, she's she's the only one with eyes
But you're the manager Lymo she can't just leave You got this like more moral support Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah All right, I got the fries On here the straight yeah, the straight okay what number is this 58 someone delivered 58 yeah I got more orders coming up wait this one's burnt how the fuck will we get we hope and only one person can see the order order up someone get the dark cola I got you okay I've got more patty's where's the rat oh my god there's his oh my god there's his I got him!
I got it!
Oh wait, there's two rats.
All right, dispose.
Put them in the trash.
Yeah, where they belong.
Is it prize two?
Number 60.
60.
All right.
Um, we only have two patties, lab.
I'm gonna go order it.
I'm gonna go order patties.
Wait.
Yeah, it's a, it's a tomato actually.
It's like directly in logic.
That's how fresh it is.
All right.
What do you mean?
Get your manager line one.
Why did you shoot that guy?
We ran out of patties.
I just saw somebody get shot.
No, no one got shot.
You're fine.
No one got shot.
We do have someone like glorped though on the can someone clean the floor?
Someone glorped on the floor.
A full customer is a happy customer.
Gotta make the customers happy, guys.
Customer with a full stomach is a happy customer.
My toilet patties.
Guys, I found more patties.
I'm happy for you Harry convinced I'm so sad We got dark I've been to my patties I put patties in there It's gone Wait what Do I see any patties in the fridge I don't see them Oh no it glitched out I believe so It's okay I have a pad Look
at us all working
Don't worry, guys.
I'm getting more patties.
Okay.
We gotta have more patties.
Alright, nice.
Nice arrest.
The gun's in the...
The gun's outside, though.
It's in the...
the customer dining hall.
What?
There was a rat outside.
I had to shoot it.
This is so doomed, you guys.
This is so doomed.
I swear to God the orders are fucking changing.
Oh, yay.
Guys, we got...
Wait, what the fuck?
Scabber, scabber!
I don't see the gun.
Am I crazy?
It's over...
Wait, I know where it is.
It's over here.
Maybe I should have got it.
I have it.
There's a glorified.
on the floor.
Can someone sweep that up?
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
I'm grilling more patties for us.
Burger, cheese, three tomato.
What it says is raw.
What the fuck?
It burnt, but it was raw.
69 is it?
yeah yeah yeah we got we got we got so many we have to restock later
does does order does the three cheese one pickle need anything else dance for the customer to make him happy next order oh they're all they're all cooked they're leaving they're leaving no there's They're still here!
They're still here!
They're 35 seconds!
The times are gone.
They're still here!
I see them!
73?
I see 78.
Oh, I would take his...
No!
78 is right here!
70 is right here!
You just keep getting quieter and quieter.
I see a 78 right here.
Oh, there's your name!
Oh, that's just busting!
Oh, goodbye everybody.
I hope you guys enjoyed your day at Sloppy's.
Please come back.
I hope the TV works for you this time.
Me too.
All right, we need more tomatoes.
Yeah, we just need more tomatoes.
Pickles and cheese.
Where's the gun?
Tomatoes, pickles, and cheese.
I really need candy to take the edge off.
Me too.
My turn.
Was it a good candy?
Heck yeah.
How good was it, bro?
It was good.
That was pretty good.
Oh yeah, I had a good ass candy too.
I don't know.
How the fuck are we supposed to do this?
If I'm getting quieter and quieter and I'm the only one that can read it.
No, I can hear you.
She just didn't take a funny little candy.
Maybe you guys should take it.
Yeah, maybe you just gotta take your edge off that.
Oh, he got chill.
Whoa, bro.
Bro, get that edge off.
Ah, chill.
Was it good?
Hey, Kyle.
It was good, Kenny.
I might explode.
No, no, no.
Everything's very dark.
Oh.
Oh, you're tripping hard, bro.
No, I'm seeing, I'm seeing a black and white man.
Oh, you're tripping hard, hard.
She had a bad candy.
Oh, look, dude.
That's like, yeah, that's a tip.
You had a tourist boat break in the kitchen.
Let's go, guys.
Come on.
I have a good ass candy.
I need my candy fix.
What'd you get?
It was just a normal candy.
That's that.
That's the good shit.
Oh, no, you're too immune to it now.
I took too many.
You gotta go to harder candies now.
before now yeah i gotta get this yeah i gotta get those jawbreakers now bro i it's not hitting it the same as before i'm not getting that same hit anymore yeah the gateway candy i gotta get into that gateway candy that's why i'll never touch a hubba
he does the worst it always it looks so innocent but then it really just Yeah, yeah, yeah, and then before you know it, you're spending your life savings on hubba bubba And juicy fruit, oh my god You ever go like double You ever go double double with hubba bubba and juicy fruit and mix it together?
Oh
Bro, it just ain't the same without hubba mix, you know It gives a little Okay, that's nice.
I'm glad.
Yeah, I can hear you.
I've always been able to hear you.
Okay, Min told me I was only getting quieter and quieter.
I think it's just mine is bugged.
Yeah, I think so, too.
Because you were fine for me.
That's good.
Okay, let's see if you guys can see the monitor.
And if not, we just die because I'm not doing that shit again.
I can see the monitor.
They're not even blank.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, they are.
They are, but we don't, I mean, we haven't taken it.
Oh, we should see it.
We're cured,
guys!
We're cured, guys!
Guys, we still don't...
Wait, do the ants respond?
I'm gonna kill the ants.
Oh, okay, that's good, because then I don't want to kill the customers anymore.
I mean, I don't...
No, no, no, no, I just...
No, they disappeared.
The customers disappeared.
It was crazy.
Oh, wait, there was already a dead ant here.
Oh, wait, you grabbed this?
Yeah, yeah, I got one.
I got the meat muncher.
He's here to munch some meat.
Damn.
Alright, got us some more patties.
Let's go.
Were there more ants in there?
Yeah, there was.
There was.
There's like one more ant.
down there wait where am I oh I can't use stairs for some reason all right I got more patties the fries oh my god oh my god did you see that wait the fucking red oh my god so fast what is donkey yelling about the rat just like the rat like fucking jumped onto the stove it's going to patty oh yeah they do that that's what they do what the fuck okay who's working on what i'm working on 89 i'm doing the patties i'll do 86 or who's doing 85 anybody nope i'm just Fuck!
Get your ass out of here.
Oh my god, I got another rat.
Three and two pickle.
These rats keep yonking my patties.
We need an exterminator.
I'm growing more patties for us.
This is burnt.
This will be bait for the rats.
Wait, I hear something.
Did you... Did you make someone mad?
Why is he mad?
Oh, there was an argument at the Sloppies.
Did you call the cops?
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
That was my patty that you fell on.
Oh, was that the angry customer?
Did he make it into a good patty?
Oh, that's good.
That's good.
We were running out.
Oh, yeah, sorry.
That was my burnt patty.
I'm using it as bait for the rat.
Watch where you're leaving your stuff, bro.
Yeah, but it's for the rats.
Wait, no, 87's being done here.
I'm making 92.
I'm making patties.
I think that's enough, right?
That should be enough patties for us.
What means to be done?
I'll do 98 92 I'm doing 92 Oh you're doing okay I'll do 93 Alright
Well I'll put more fries in there
Oh my god Oh wait I saw one three more patties Before we go Is there any more rats downstairs in the tunnels Yeah Oh, two parties.
Oh, goodbye.
Let's see, I got it.
I got snubbed.
Don't worry, you're coming.
You ain't leaving this job yet.
You work here forever, snubbed.
This is your...
Whoa, oh.
You can't leave snopies.
This is your life.
now I got the last battery okay wait where's the oh what the fuck yeah I was gonna say what happened to my battery order up oh shit no my burn patties um so we're gonna oh wait Are there any more rats in the basement?
Oh, whoa, whoa, let's time...
Oh, wait, who has the gun?
Why are the orders not going away?
Um...
They're not going away from me!
Oh my god.
Okay, I gotta shoot a rat.
I'll be right back.
I wonder... I don't even know if we have enough rats anymore.
I think we got all of them.
I think we destroyed the rat economy.
Oh, no, there's a lot of rat.
Oh, there's a lot.
There you go.
That's good.
oh oh um well let's hope there's no angry customers above because this is more important oh shit okay that'll be unfortunate i died there and then like they'll be like where the fuck dookigo who am i kidding they'll just be like where did the patties go my life isn't important that important it's lobbies all right all right i got The meat.
So, um, I left the gun downstairs and it's- there's no bullets.
Oh, wait, why am I- oops?
I forgot- I'm sorry.
I brought an extra raw.
I forgot to cook the meat a little bit.
I forgot about the- the- the second step.
I skipped step two and five.
It's in the tunnels.
Wait, we had a patty box since when?
I got a heal later.
Do we have enough patty's?
Because I'm making more soon.
It's in the...
It's in the tunnels.
I just threw it downstairs and called it a day.
I got a heal.
take my smoke break give me a sec I'm taking my smoke break
all right there's so many oh you got the goop nice so my paddies disappeared I'm getting where patties because my original patty box disappeared.
I got it.
We work until we die because we love sloppies.
I got more patties.
Oh, it came back?
No.
You mean this is wrong?
That's not fucking wrong.
I'm like.
Yeah, no, it bugs out like that sometimes.
It's a little freaky.
Okay, who's doing order two?
Is it gonna do two?
I'll do two.
I'm grilling patties.
Why don't we serve so many people we look at that?
I know, our Yelp review is so...
We have, like, five stars.
We're the best-selling fast food restaurant here.
We're at a lettuce!
Wait, the fried done!
Fried done!
Thank you, thank you!
Sorry.
Oh.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh shit, why me?
What?
It slapped that Nimi and slapped me.
What the fuck?
It like looked at you and slapped me.
There's a big guy.
there's a big guy wait oh day's over yay oh he still killed him nice mr.
strong actually catching oh there's me this is me why is doki throwing doki away no i'm just if one feels just like a customer i want to know what's like wait why is your body there because i got fucking get grabbed by by the vent man i didn't pay the vent toll whoa whoa i can't even grab oh there we go there you go that's scary i feel like i can pay i'm gonna pay a rent now what are we gonna take oh pay the bills
Oh, we did it.
Do it again, Mr. Strong.
Did someone just pay the rent or did we just lose $400?
No, I pay the rent.
Okay.
Dude, we paid the rent.
We made it.
We made it, guys!
Go.
Let's go.
Yeah.
La-di-da.
I wish we could do amongst them.
I would say that the Sloppy sisters have moved on up.
Yay.
Also, Nimi did a lot of fry cooking, which is so appropriate and i love that yeah i know she was our fry gal look at that guys the franchise is a success guys sloppy's in space look they're fighting like pokemon that's yeah fighting yeah yeah yeah save actually the save stays intact if we didn't fail it so we can keep that for the next time if you want oh yeah that's it yeah we're definitely coming back Yeah.
I would love the work in service industry again.
Smooth out the order screens.
I think it would be really good.
Yeah.
I mean, the fact...
Oh.
Okay.
It's crazy that it's just early access, though.
I wonder what else they're going to do with it after.
I think I'll need my burger after us.
Oh, true.
The sloppy burger!
I wonder if...
Oh my god, they're hitting us with everything.
They're like, you ain't leaving.
Oh, I heard you wanted to leave.
No, we're gonna turn the power off.
I'll turn it back on.
Hey.
That's my job.
I'm getting that promotion.
Guys, I did it!
I turned on the power!
My kids fall.
I don't know my brain is like, I gotta keep, guys, there's so much to do.
I mean, you can't stop.
You can stop.
We're done.
Oh my god.
These cavities wasted.
They are wasted, but that's okay.
That's okay.
It's for the rats.
It's not a waste if we- Here, here.
Here, here.
You get one?
Yeah, I get one.
Yeah.
Nibble on you.
Oh, yeah.
It has a rat preservative.
Of course for you.
Wait, there's enough for somebody.
I made just enough for everyone.
Wait, I can throw it?
this place down wait can we lay give
me a sec don't worry i got you oh wait wait you're live
we're the strongest It is trying.
Are you hiding behind me?
I love sloppies.
Oh shit, I missed.
Give me a sec.
Let me-
You have to come out.
Wait, what can't shoot you while you're in there?
What are you doing?
Oh shit!
Oh shit, you're not gonna hit shit!
You're not gonna hit anything!
What the hell?
You're gonna cheat me!
You're gonna beat me!
Oh shit!
Wait, I'm alive!
Wait.
You shot my leg, you didn't shoot my head.
Stupid.
Oh dang.
Wait.
Movement.
Oh.
Wait, where are you?
Yeah, you can't shoot me when I'm getting mopped up.
That's a key, right?
That's two shots.
I just wanted to end it.
We couldn't leave the purgatory.
Why me?
I was trying to free us!
I wanted to free us!
Oh, okay.
Violet, man.
Where she started so...
You guys are here.
Straight up, don't kill me.
What do you mean?
She's straight up killed me.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I'm about to die.
I'm about to die.
And then there was one.
The manager lives.
I need to get back.
I know you're going to unmute everybody.
Yeah, I'm unmuting everyone.
Hello?
Hello, yeah, I hear you.
I'm slowly unmuting people.
I'm unmuting.
Yeah, yeah, I'm unmuting.
I can't believe the manager lived in the end.
I can.
Why did you guys resist?
I was trying to free us from purgatory.
I wanted to die by a different hand, you know?
By whose hand?
Who was you?
Who are you to decide how I passed?
You still died!
You still...
I killed you, though.
I killed you.
You still left.
I lived.
GG's ever...
It was an honor and pleasure to watch.
It was a pleasure and honor to to work at Sloppy's again in space.
Yes, yeah, I had a wonderful time.
It was wonderful getting to hang with you as well for the first time, Nimmy.
It was awesome.
Yeah, thank you guys.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for joining us.
Yeah.
Thank you for coming.
Maybe next time Severance will come out and then we can.
We'll play it.
Yeah.
Hopefully, and Minkin finally haunts us after Halloween.
For real.
Cool.
Thanks, guys.
TGs, everyone.
Have a great night.
TGs.
I take my hat to eat.
Go for it.
Sorry, Lyme.
What the fuck, Max?
You microaggressions.
God damn.
You were the manager, Lyme.
You deserved it.
Wait, you killed us all.
We all say, we all talk smack when you turn corn.
We're like, God, that Lyme, she smells so good, like a nice citrus.
What?
even her face looks like a lime move yeah yeah she's kind of she's kind of she smells kind of like a ferret i don't know oh they smell pretty bad don't they smell i think it's a good spell yeah they have aura go sleep go sleep oh yeah it's so late for you jesus everyone good night everyone
That was really, oh my gosh, my floating, my fucking ghost hats.
But that was fun.
I had a great time with the sloppy sisters and the side of Mimi fries.
That was a fun, fun time.
I'm glad I was able to find this.
We had like, by the way, like we were like throwing out games because like obviously like the original game we wanted to play did not work out for us.
the game did not come up because it was like they're like oh shit yeah steam like rejected the game because it has a little error so like yeah you're not getting the game today and so we like spitball a ton of games and then like i think like uh i think like we were like brainstorming games last night and like this morning and like none of the games were really vibing with us because like i said um i said this in the memory stream but the hardest part is that when it is fighting games that are more for more than four people that's like the hardest part just because like a lot of games are just four players max you know so we were just spitballing ideas i was like i have like a whole wish list of like um i have a wish list that um that i look at for uh multiplayer games And I was just,
like, browsing through, like, me, Mint, Snuffy, and Limeo were just looking through all the games that we have, like, saved up and bookmarked.
So I was like, oh, what about Keep Digging, Guilty as Sock, Bunker Invaders, and then we're like, oh, maybe we should get something spooky that's, like, the same themed as Severance, the spooky game that Mint wanted to play.
um and then so then like snuffy suggested yep yeah pizza delivery jackbox and then i was like oh why do there's predator hunting grounds that's sort of like the spooky ghost but instead of a ghost you can play the predator but and i was like oh wait that might not work because it's very aim reliant though if you're if you want to play the predator you gotta be able to shoot your gun I didn't say I was gonna mention on I was mentioned as planet mentioned on stream because I was like Oh,
I just know how I found and then and then later on I was like wait guys I found the perfect game and it was burger bots um and like it has like at that time when I found it we we found it well I found it at like 8 in the morning so that's why I need a nap time because like um you know my sleep schedule but I'm fixing it today because I said um I said I would fix and the end of the week is not yet is not yet there yet so don't worry i'm fixing um i'm getting my life i'm getting my shit together by the end of this day but anyway um i stayed up the whole night because i woke up i took a nap last yesterday and i've been taking a lot of naps and that's not good um it's um it's not been very healthy um but yeah i woke up at like two in the morning and i i stayed up all the way to like 10 a.m um because obviously like my my schedule is just nap time when i'm tired uh and then like i was like oh my god i need to take another i don't think i'll be okay if i just power through till three so um
so then i like went back to i took another nap time um don't worry at the end of the day i'll get my shit together um but yeah like i found the game
Like, how am I going to find more multiplayer games?
And the thing is, Zentrea, all she does, like, not all she does, but she loves playing, like, friend slop and multiplayer games.
Not just friend slop, but, you know, for some, I don't know how she does it, but I feel like every time I pop, I see her stream.
She's playing, like, the newest multiplayer game.
So I was just like, all right, I have Zentrea on my friend's list.
I'm just, I was looking at all the games she's playing.
Alright, somehow, I don't know how she does it, but every day she finds a new multiplayer game to play on stream.
And, uh, so I was just, I literally, like, went to your profile, clicked on all games, and I was like, yoink.
I was like, oh, Burger Vox, I've never seen this game before.
And I was like, oh, wait, this is perfect.
It's a fast food simulator in space with, like, horror themes.
I was like, wait, that's, that's perfect.
need to do any research i'll just i was like oh my god i don't have to do any research i could just mooch off of zen and enjoying the friend stuff yeah so so i was like guys i found i found the game perfect game for all of us and i was like guys hey look at that let's play this one all of this game and we're like all right let's go and then that's how that's how i discovered burger bots
i didn't yeah i don't do any work perfect just like a manager at a fast food restaurant um yeah i had a great time playing with everyone i hope this audio was okay um our audio team wasn't available um so uh my manager had to do the audio balancing and um he was like well the well the proximate chat's pretty shit but like i think it's okay and i was like oh i hope it's okay yeah he's like he's like proximate chat's shit but like i think it's okay and i'm like oh okay i hope it's okay then it was as good as proximate chat can get yeah yeah So,
yeah, I'm glad that everyone, um, um, I'm glad that everyone could, uh, could hear everyone.
That's all that matters.
Anyway, guys, I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
It's always fun playing with the sloppy sisters and also the sad and Mimi Fry's.
Um, I love working in the service industry.
Said everyone.
It's always a great time.
But yeah, I hope you guys all enjoyed the stream.
I hope you guys had lots of great laughs.
I'm gonna head off now, guys, to take...
Okay, I shouldn't take my nap, but God, I really wanted to...
Guys, I told myself, I get my shit together today.
Today's the last day where I get my shit together.
I stay where I can get my shit together.
Next, you think of the Super Chat.
Thank you.
It's fun to watch y'all suffer.
The Super Chat.
Thank you.
All right, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get them around to get that blood flowing.
And if you step for me, head to bed, guys.
You deserve it.
I actually, I don't know what I plan next week.
Other than, other than, um, I think I'm going to put two Batman, like, two Batman playthroughs for next.
next week.
But other than that, I don't really have any plans.
I don't think I have any collabs arranged for next week.
We'll see.
Um, maybe like, I'll ask Cheeby if she wants to do Little Nightmares, like, uh, three next week if she has time.
Um, but other than that, there's nothing, like, planned yet, uh, for next week.
Um, but definitely two Batman playthroughs, because, like, um, you know, one of, there's so many controls in Batman that I think I'll need it.
I think I definitely think I'll need me to play throughs because I'm gonna forget the controls if I don't Um, but anyway guys, uh, I'm gonna head off now.
Uh, I'll see you guys next week.
Bye.
Bye, everyone Uh, but oh wait before I before I forgot the shill guys guys.
Okay, not not goodbye yet.
I got a shill first Guys, guys, did you guys know?
Uh, oh my gosh, there's so many things to shill.
Did you guys know?
Oh my gosh, where's the image?
That there is a limited drop of the birthday concert merch.
When it's gone, it's gone forever.
We're not planning on restocking.
This was sold at Anime Expo.
So we have remaining stock left over from Anime Expo.
So yeah, when it's gone, it's gone forever.
So get it, get it now.
now now now um i'm spamming the link uh in the chat anyway that's the show of the day i'll see you guys later everybody bye guys bye